Joe Rogan and spirit who will keep that
and keep my stupid fucking stumbling
over my own tongue fat face.
[inaudible] the Joe Rogan experience.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
there's a link. If you click on it,
you enter in the code name Rogan and
you get 15% off your masturbation.
Goodness. All right, here we go
with the show. Buckle up bitches,
the Joe Rogan experience.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
ladies and gentlemen,
the lovely and talented Mr
Bill Burr has joined us. He's going
on. How are you? How are you fella?
I'm fantastic. I'm enjoying my
coconut water. This is shit, isn't it?
It's going to be all product
placement. Yeah, it should be three.
They sent me a couple of cases of
this stuff. It's fucking awesome.
Do you know something? If anybody
else offered me a coconut water,
I wouldn't have done it. I'd be like,
that sounds like some gross, uh,
Vegan whole shit at. But just because it
was you when you always read like that,
you know, dude, I was on a, you know,
fucking coconut science.com read this
whole thing about it so well somebody just
stops man.
Once after Jujitsu classes at Duda I work
out with brought like a whole bunch of
them to class.
Was it an apology after he body
slammed you with something here though?
I have some coconut water
though. Nice gesture, but it's
fucking delicious. It's a,
it's, it doesn't feel, it doesn't,
it's not as boring as water,
but it doesn't feel like you're drinking
juice or something where it's like
heavy and Sarah be and
you know what I mean?
That I absolutely still shit. I'm gonna
love it. And this, this stuff is healthy.
Yeah. Yeah. That's really good for
seriously, if you drink a lot of Gatorade,
see I drink a lot of
Gatorade cause I drink a lot.
So I've kind of switched my
Gatorade out for coconut water.
That's all I drink when I work out.
Now how I drink Gatorade if I get the
stomach flu or like a food poisoning or
whatever the hell I had. Like yeah, like
last week. Yeah. They have PTO light.
That's,
that's something that's actually even
better for you because it's all balanced
out. Like when guys dehydrate, when
they cut weight, they drink pedialyte,
isn't it for me? I don't
have any kids. Yeah.
Everybody who has a kids was just
saying, no, no, no, not gateway.
Do you want to get PDO?
Like why does that,
that the beginning of
that word just scared me.
He just having a beard and not having any
children being a Caucasian, I can't go.
You don't even that Pto light for the
pdf file over here. My names in the mix.
Carrots, the name's not, that's a
little unfortunate, right? Media Light.
It should be, you know, some sort of
a super electrolyte drink. You know,
obviously means kid like pediatrician.
Well it's,
I think it's designing for it
for children when they get sick,
if they're dehydrated because you
want to make sure that they get enough
electrolytes or fucks them up. Yeah. You
know there's plenty of kids out there.
There are. Look at the one
there. Oh dear. Your own bill.
You'll see and you'll see when they had
half looks like you and no matter how
bad your day is,
when you to [inaudible]
people used to say that your
two minutes to drive me nuts.
You'll see when you have young kids
would be like, we shut the fuck up.
You're all wrapped up
in your own bullshit.
You got this little fucking human being.
It was an accident.
You shot a load into a woman.
The A's divided. Come on man,
what the fuck are you talking about? Half
looks like you and half the trick, man.
It's a fucking biological trick,
but then you have one. You Go, Whoa,
this is a different,
I never considered the amount of
responsibility and attachment and just the
biological attachment you have to them.
Oh No, no, I'm not. I'm not crazy.
I'm not saying that it is an amazing, oh
no, I know you're not. No, you're not.
A lot of times I say things, I say things
and they become misconstrued. Yeah,
you build.
It doesn't like that.
Slurping by the way is just for all you
fucking getting angry that I slept my
coffee. I get all these people
emailing me easy drinking. You cough,
you mute the microphone.
When he drinking
during your pants.
I gotta admit that's one of my pet peeves.
When I watched your movie.
I hate if there's a scene where
the actors are eating. I hit mute.
I can't listen to it because they fucking,
you know actors,
they've got to make an interesting,
they can't just eat. They got up,
we're going to fucking fucking robbed
the bank and they start throwing shit in
their mouth and it drives me nuts.
Just the sound of somebody's lip smacking
or like when you're a car with a girl
that you just got in a fight with and
she's eating Doritos and get to hear it
like echoing off her skull, the crunching
noise issues. This mother Fucker,
he turned that into
shit. Yeah, he went to his own
life. I have a fucking pet peeve.
It's a weird one, but when I
see someone eating in the movie,
I secretly hoped they had to do a hundred
fucking takes and they all threw up.
I can can't keep eating because
it just seems so forced.
You know you're eating while you're
having this conversation, you know,
like what you were saying. No, we're going
rubbers, folk on break. He's got a mouth.
I'm on point with the bread was shit.
You wouldn't do it.
People will fuck is pointing with
their sandwich. He'd be like,
this guy is an asshole.
He's one.
He's fucking sandwich at me and telling
me what's going to happen some way.
You know? That's some
weird intimidation. Shit.
You ever have someone fucking talk to
you and in the middle of we had talking,
they put a hand on your knee, squeeze
your knee while they're talking to you.
It's like,
what is happening here?
I got it. I got a couple of those.
I mean, one time I liked it.
I was shooting a pilot for some show
that never got picked up and it was,
it was hilarious because, uh, what the
hell happened? Basically what they wanted,
an edgy show, you know, all
these things always start.
So we give them this edgy
show and right around,
right before we did the run through the
don imus thing went down what he said,
nappy headed hoes.
So the industry gets so terrified,
it's not even just about radio now
becomes about this frigging pilot.
So they were already
nervous about the jokes.
So we went in there and one of
the first jokes was, um, I dunno,
some homeless guy comes up and as you
know me for some change, um, you know,
on the liberal guy, no,
no, I don't want that.
And the other guy was a republican guy
and he turns around and he flicks ice
cream and it hits them right in
the face. It was hilarious. Right.
So they basically,
they freaked out and then they didn't
laugh at any jokes who are doing this run
through and do it. I'm telling you,
we're absolutely bombing. Okay.
Now to me it's hilarious and it's not
even that big a deal because I've bombed
horrifically by myself. I'm bombing
with the group. It's funny. Easier. Yes.
I'm walking into scenes and the other
actors, I see the deer in the headlights,
I'm almost laughing.
And the more it bombs,
the harder I'm committing to these jokes.
So anyways,
so the whole thing tanks and
by the end of it, you know,
me and the other guy like,
dude, I'm getting fired. He's
like, no, I'm getting fired.
So he ended up going back to the hotel
and everybody shows up to talk about it
and you know the creators of the show,
I'll come walking in along with
the director and I'm standing up.
I let him to run,
the fucking director comes walking in,
sits down in my bed and then reaches over,
had some pain,
it's there and just grabs a handful
and start and starts eating.
And I just wanted to be like, yeah
dude, yeah, make yourself at home,
have some fucking peanuts. But I was
so in that I'm going to get fired.
I was trying to be the nice guy.
And that's like one of those things that
slowly killing me is every once in a
while like, you know,
it was like years ago,
I'll be driving down the highway and I
just think of that motherfucker sitting
down eating my goddamn peanuts, and I
talked to you about it and you're like,
dude, that's like some Alpha male shit.
He comes into your placement live.
He starts eating your food.
That is a weird thing that people do.
Some people just open refrigerator
and start eating. I don't like that.
Now that drives me nuts.
The only person that I mind,
I don't mind it is Brian Cowen and
Joey and Joey always ask Brian Cowen,
I'll come in my fucking kitchen.
This dude's Eaton Pumpkin Pie.
He's got whip cream on it and shit. I'm
like, you, you broke up the whip cream.
You made yourself a plate of Pumpkin
and you broke out the whip cream and
everything. I got all mine with
Brian, Brian's my brother. I mean,
he can do whatever the fuck he wants.
Doesn't bother me, but it's still crazy.
I wouldn't do it if I'm over your house.
Somebody I'm gonna need.
You don't even get a drink water. I'm
going to wait. I'm going to ask you. Hey,
can I have a water? I know you're going
to say yes, but I have to ask you.
I'm not gonna eat your fucking
Pumpkin pie and put whipped cream
pill. Then I could let go
of chef, stuff like that.
I'd like a high school teacher called
me the dumbest kid in the room and I'll
still think about that.
There was a 20 something years ago.
I have the same issue.
I talk about it on stage.
I reenact arguments from 1997
screaming at your windshield.
That's what I do now. Now let me tell
you something. Math teacher. Well,
I'm glad I over all the years though,
although all the stupid ideas that
I've had about arguments in my head,
I've avoided all physical altercations.
I've never had a physical altercation of
kid. I've had situations where, you know,
a long time ago, I wish I told this
guy that or I wish I told them this,
but the reality is it's way better
than I didn't cause what if he went,
well fuck you.
And then he fucking throws a rock at me
and then all of a sudden were two men
biting each other. You don't,
you don't go that route.
Wrestling in the street like fucking
children. You know what the fuck is that?
When I was a kid, my dad came home from
work once with a fucking black eye.
My Step Dad's business was going,
it was falling apart and at one point
shit got squirrelly in him and his partner
fucking duked it out
is crazy. Yeah, he can.
Youtube wasn't around then.
You know,
there'd be some sort of
security who was like, Whoa,
aren't you looking your fucking forties
it's like, what is happening? It was,
it was disappointing.
Embarrassing. It was sad.
It was a bunch of different
things all at once.
It was bad ass on any level that your
stepdad could still throw down. No,
he could. I think he got his ass kicked.
I'm pretty sure that's embarrassing.
I'm sure. I'm pretty sure he got sucker
punched and then uh, he hit the guy back.
He punched the guy in the stomach,
but I don't know who punched who first,
but it's just fucking pathetic.
This guy was his friend and this guy used
to come over to the house and we used
to, you know, we all still
have family dinners together.
Like him and his wife would come
over to the house and there was,
this is my dad's partner and then all of
a sudden they're fucking duking it out
at work. Cause the, the business
fell apart. Who was very,
very strange to come over for dinner again
or no, they became friends again. Yeah,
they, they, they stayed
friends. You know, they just,
they've duked it out as friends
and then they stayed friends.
But it was just embarrassing
and he was embarrassed to,
he felt like such a fucking idiot. He
came home with a black eye, you know,
it's like, what am I dealt with? Ayroni
man to read, pick up the friendship.
It'd be easier if I won the fight,
if I lost the fight,
that would be in the back of
mind. You want the rematch? Uh,
at some point you get used to,
when you do Jujitsu a lot,
you get used to getting beat comes formal.
That's a different thing.
They're going to fight and then like, hey,
let's, let's try these techniques. It,
you know,
if like what if we had some big argument
about we were going to combine our
podcasts and then it just didn't go well
and I didn't give you the money for the
microphones and then we duked
it out and you somehow lost.
I somehow surprised you and it had
all feel like one in a million chance.
I somehow caught you. I would feel
way stupid or that we're fighting.
I would feel way stupid. Other
than that, it's my buddies. I know,
but you're martial artists that
get it yet, but just right now
go in peace. You've got
[inaudible]. It's always worth,
you wouldn't see me in there and like I
got my back turned you down and my head,
I'd be like, what bill? How
can you host me in the face?
Did that Ron Howard look and
Jackie has that wouldn't bug you.
Depends on if you really just told me up.
Like all of a sudden you
just fucking unload like uh,
a one to leg kick combination
on me and robbed me.
You hit me with a liver shot and dropped
me in a, and then I had a tap out. Yeah.
Then I'd probably want some sort
of a rematch. Let me ask you this,
which really upset,
which you lose a belt class.
Would you have to go back down to Brown
belt? Purple Belt? You don't lose,
I mean the only way you get the ideas that
you're a certain level of proficiency,
but it doesn't mean that
someone can't get you.
What if I started tapped all the time?
If my face do your Dojo,
there's no way you'd have
to lose out when a bill
who's next and I'm just sitting there
with a stupid look on my face. You know,
competition is healthy.
I think it's fun and everything,
but when it gets in the real world,
like as far as like fighting
people and shit like that,
it's too squirrely because
you don't just fight someone.
They get mad and they come back and they
want to bring a baseball bat or fucking
stab you or shoot you. I never
fought outside my family past June.
Outside class you in
junior high? Oh yeah, let's get
started getting to be like, you know,
buck and a quarter and like knew
how to becoming coordinated through.
I saw one kid take a pounding
and I was just like, yeah,
I'm sticking with the jokes. It
was this kid who, he was Jack,
he's one of those man childs, you
know, and like in like eighth grade,
you know they aren't,
they could like beat up the teacher but
then they get to high school and they
just stopped growing and then
they're just this little fireplug.
But in eighth grade that's like the,
that's their peak.
And this kid was at his apex of,
of physical fitness and he
was fighting this doughy,
this baby who we looking kid and they
go to get off the bus and baby who is
behind Manchild and he just, you know,
he just pushed him down from behind,
jumped,
got on his chest and it was just,
he just started teeing off of his head
and it was one of those, you know,
when people go crazy and
then it becomes disgusting.
Like the crowd was just like,
oh. And I was just like,
he was just beating the fuck out of him.
He didn't come to school for the rest of
the week and he came back the next week
and the swelling in his face, he had
come down probably 80% but he listens.
Manchild still didn't look
and he had a look in his eye.
I remember his confidence
was shaken. I'm I, it was, it
was amazing, man. I was like,
you saw it was a,
it was a moment in his life and I remember
just looking at that going, yeah, yeah,
def, it was funny because I
almost went out with that baby.
He was a kid I would've gotten
killed. And he's like, he just,
he would have stabbed me with
the, the fucking kid. No,
he used to get bullied
and he just, I dunno, uh,
he was used to getting the crap kicked
out of him by people like two years older,
which is basically
you're in seventh grade.
Like that two years is a
huge jump physically. And uh,
it's like you're sitting there, you
know, like, okay, I'm going to fight you.
And the other guys, like you
got like a beard, you know,
smashing you over the head. So, um, yeah.
So all my fights were basically within
my family and I had four brothers,
so I used to practice on my three younger
ones and then try to take my older
brother where the psychological
advantage over me. So
all the brothers always have
an advantage. Yeah. I can beat.
I had a friend who's a older brother,
used to beat the fuck out of him and it
tortured him late into like adulthood.
He was in his late thirties and it
was fucked. It fucked his head up.
He always wanted to get
back at his brother.
He used to go over his brother's house
and his brother wasn't home and steal
shit from him. Like he would go like
his wife, his brother's wife was there.
He'd say hi.
And again,
John told me to go pick something up
and you'd go in and just steal from his
brother was still in friendship rather
than the other way the fuck out of him.
His brother beat the fuck out of them.
My brother was like two years older
and just used to just box him up.
He used to fucking really hurt them
and intimidate the shit out of him.
I got one for Ya.
I went last time I fought
my youngest brother, uh, I forget
where we went out and about.
My Dad came in to break it
up and like a piece of shit.
I did one more over my dad's shoulder,
caught them and it made that classic like
Hollywood should have rec recorded the
sound for like the punch in the face was
that classic but like with a little bit
of lip sounds caught him
right in the mouth. And uh,
I knew what bugged him and then what
would it for like 15 years we would be out
drinking. And like when he
got on his third drink, I
would feel him sizing me up.
I felt it.
I felt that I was just going,
is this in my head or is
this dude sizing me up?
And then like years later I'm drinking
with my other brother and we were talking
about, and I'm going, yeah,
he doesn't think I noticed,
but I feel him size and up.
He goes, oh yeah, dude. He goes, every
time I drink with them, he brings that.
And like by then he was a little bit
taller than me and he had that, that,
that anger and stuff. But, uh, I just
want to, I want to just tied them up.
Like I got to a point where I just,
you know,
I'm going to strategy play that you
had dug out of the sucker punch.
Get the clench.
Yeah.
My older brother came at me a baobab
11 years ago and like a red roof inn.
It was some, some sort of bullshit. Uh,
and he came flying at me, you know, my
brother is no joke. He can fight and I,
I just tied them up.
I had been,
but I had the advantage where he
has a real job so he has to work.
I can sit here and going on hikes
and going to the gym and stuff.
So I was in cardio, I was in better
shape, so I just, I just tied them up.
Hello Jeff. Time up for not, not long
too. And he was like, he was teen.
Second was liking cubicle shape. He
had like that initial, I'm going to,
I'm going to kill you. But
this is the thing though, if
he would have, if I didn't,
uh, tie him up. Yeah. That's all
I, it's, it's like in hockey when,
when someone goes out on a fight,
they just grabbed the guy
in like bear hug them.
I just thought it did that and I was, uh,
how was it? He was kind of on top of me,
but I just, I just said I'm sort of
smothered in there. I was like, dude,
I'm not gonna find nothing. Can he
didn't talk to me for a year. Wow.
You didn't talk to me for a year. And what
was he mad about? I don't, it was, dude,
it's that family shit. Some,
I dunno, something from 1974.
I'm glad I don't have bread off cause I
would not want to grow up with someone
like me if I was a brother,
if I either like one or two things would
have happened would have been either we
would join an alliance and fucking start
a team take on the world and tag team
chicks or we would fight to the death.
It's going to be one or the other.
I don't really see any of
the other options. Yeah.
So which one's going
to be fucker? Yeah. No,
I think there's a reason why you
didn't have a brother. Cause I,
whenever I talked to him,
he has like,
you'll have like a couple of parakeets
and they somehow have a fight to the
death. Like, dude, I don't know what's
with Perkins. They just go at it too.
It's like you're way more mellow.
When I met you in the nineties dude,
this guy was like in game seven energy.
It's so fun.
Everyone keeps on saying that the way,
way more mellow.
I think we're just now feel comfortable
to tell him now. Is that what it is?
Not [inaudible] you're now so
mellow. We can talk about it. No,
but I was way more angrier when I met him.
You know what I mean?
It's one of those things while
you're, you're, yeah, you're, yeah,
your twenties you're processing what
the fuck just happened to you when your
first 20th hopefully you had a
good childhood. If you didn't,
you end up in show business
or whatever and then you know,
you kind of thinking back
to that stuff. So, yeah. You know?
Yeah. I'm kind of just realizing how,
how much of a difference it must be for
people because so many fucking people
bring it up and I try to think like,
what the fuck I was like when
I was younger that I don't
think I was a Douchebag,
but I definitely think I had
douchebag tendencies. You know,
like if you were a Douche
bag to me I could just go
full douche right back at Ya.
And it gets stuck in some stupid ass
douchey argument that really rationally I
shouldn't have been caught into it.
Like your energy man,
you are on the balls of your feet,
you will fucking ready.
It was like your energy was like
you had just gotten into a fight.
Well you met me.
I was only probably when,
what do you mean when I 96 96.
Wow. That's a lot of years later.
That so's thinking you probably met
me earlier in the nineties when I, uh,
my last fight I think was like an 89.
I took a while for me to just wind
down as a human being from that,
just from the idea of competing,
because most of my life from 15 to
21 was just competing in martial arts
tournaments. That's all I dare you would
like a retired athlete and now you just,
you know,
21 you know,
it's all of a sudden I'm trying to do
comedy and I still have this fucking weird
mind. You know, that's tuned in
for physical plan to hand combat.
You're still in blood.
Sport is so stupid.
When I look back and think
about what I have done that now,
there's no fucking way.
I'm not going to fight somebody for
free and dedicate my whole life to doing
this,
traveling around the country and kicking
people in the head like that's what I'm
gonna do it and they're going to kick
me travel now. Nobody covers shit.
You had to pay for your
own travel everywhere.
He had to pay for your own hotel room.
We sleep like a bunch of
people in a hotel room.
Like one of us would sleep on the
floor. One guy was sleeping, one bed,
one guy was sleeping in another bed,
one guy would sleep in that tub.
We just slept a bunch of guys in rooms.
Everyone who was broke and we're all
fighting full contact with no fucking no
protection. I mean you, you,
you have like this little
chest protector on your body.
But the really scary thing,
the really scary thing is your feet.
It's not,
it's not punches and it's kicking
someone in the head. It's a scary shit.
So after awhile, what part of
your foot do you use? So it hurts,
the less the least.
Who has you just get used to kick your
head is going to hurt a lot more than my
foot is. You know, it, it will hurt.
Like I've broken my foot on people's
Shins and a broken my foot on elbows.
But you're, you're, it's like between
like kicking someone in the head.
It doesn't really hurt your foot.
And I go out,
Family Guy Miller had gone somewhere
and it would be over if you'd catch them
with the toes. You see that a lot
in fights. Like it's more of a slap.
But if somebody like solidly kicks you in
the head, man, God, if you do it right,
almost everybody goes out.
It's like scary things.
I watched those bus route
videos where he just,
I dunno like watching that guy like
he was so everybody was so afraid of
of that liver shot. Oh yeah.
Richard Pryor victim a minute.
But where he talked about how he came out
with his hands high in the guy. Right,
right.
In the next round he comes out,
he's going to say elbows down by his
waist and then they're doing this like,
I don't know. I watch his videos and
it's like this amazing like information
and then just completely Hillel
like the guys is Great. We had one,
the podcast I saw that you had that
you haven't listened to a yard.
That guy is fucking a killing machine
and he's absolutely hilarious.
Did you see that one where he goes,
he walks in.
If you see somebody fucking your wife,
I give him the gun and then I take
out the nine. It's just a hilarious,
he's crazy.
He's the fighting days and he did.
He did the bare knuckle Pancrase days
where you weren't allowed to punch to the
face,
but you're allowed to punch the body
and you can open palm slap each other in
the face. Just so much more
humiliating. Yeah. Yes.
Well he knock guys out like
that and he's such a savage.
He figured out if you just pull your hand
way back and throw it like a punch and
they use the palm of your, your fist
instead of like slapping them in,
hitting him with the hand,
which is kind of flexible.
It gives into the shot of you hit him
with the palm. It's like it's a bone,
it's a,
and it's a bone that you really don't
have to worry about breaking unlike your
hands. How can you punch someone
in the face? Bare knuckle.
You really have to worry about
breaking your hands. Yeah, he's,
people don't realize that.
Like a lot of [inaudible] not stab,
Smash Bang, Bang, goodbye thing.
And you know what's funny is
that sound effect is so funny,
but you're watching him. His
form is perfect. Yeah. Oh yeah.
He's got some fucking great stories
about brawls too. You know, he managed,
imagine picking a fight
with that fucking guy. What?
I want a giant dantic mistake.
Apparently there was some football
player that got mouthy with them.
Boss accidentally stepped on the
guy's foot and the guy goes, you know,
he's a little animated and get a little
crazy and other guy didn't know until
afterwards. But you know, boss gets
a little animated and he's at a bar,
I guess he was just really loud
and he's fun guy, you know,
and you just tell them some
story or somebody stepped
on this guy's foot and the
guy got just really do shit with him. And
he goes, I'm sorry, I apologize. My fault.
Let me buy you a drink and the guy
has no fuck you and fuck your drink.
And you're like, got in
his face. And he said,
you want to take this outside of
class room and goes, sure, okay,
let's take it outside. And then his
friends come up to him and goes, dude,
you know what the fuck you're doing.
Okay. You know, he's just some,
we just a big dude and thought I'm going
to go outside and fuck up this bald guy.
He's got a giant mistake.
Yeah.
But this guy is way bigger this because
of football and football players. Man,
I was in Phoenix once,
I was in tamping,
it was going to the Improv
and some fucking kid was
there. Who's a one of the uh,
Arizona state guys who's playing
what professional football now.
He was so big,
right?
Like you don't realize like how big that
kind of big is that Bas Rutten is like
215 pounds. That's like, that's nothing
compared to these guys in a bar in Utah.
And there was a guy who
used to play quarterback for
like Oregon or Oregon state
and I was just looking at a guy
going, that's a, that's a quarterback.
That's cause they looked like rag dolls
when they get hit on TV. This guy was,
he was like six, five, like two 40 yeah.
And he was still in shape and
it's like that guy, you know,
if a linebacker comes from behind,
he doesn't seem as head snaps back
and he's on the ground like all woozy.
Are you a football fan? Yeah.
Football. Hockey to you.
When you see guys like collide, when
you see like a really bad hit, you know,
does it, does it fucking
freak out when you see that?
When you see like a guy go out?
Not really in foot. It's hockey.
Hockey is because
hockey players, I don't know that
they're as big as football players,
but they're going like 15,
20 miles an hour.
I don't know that you can
obviously go faster on skates,
but just sometimes like
when guys, uh, you know,
the head shots sometimes in hockey,
if you just watch a guy, you know,
I've seen a couple of guys
that their careers got ended.
Somebody's phone is
somebody buzzing some mung?
I don't even have a phone on me. That's
boss calling in the show. Joe Rogan.
It's bus route then. Yeah. Uh,
your comb is here too, somewhere.
Joe. Does he still have his comb? Uh,
laying around here, I probably
got 80 emails about that comb. Uh,
we were going to auction it off. Oh
there it goes. A couple of Buddhas
I was telling, I was telling, I'm
sure this is still nice and clean. Um,
it is, he has a blue stuff. He
keeps your use the Tacoma ball hairs
special. No, I played drums and a lot of
times I'll play right before I go out.
So it would like the headphones on.
I get like this weird like it's,
it's not even a hat head,
it's a head headphone head and it
comes down here on the side so it just,
you know, push my hair up
and go like that. So I saw
him would go to what do you,
what do you like fucking John Travolta
and racist and all the things that we
always wondered who still buys combs.
My dad still carries around a comb
and I always tried to like try it up.
Like there's something
to it if my dad uses it.
So like I always try to do it but it
does nothing for me. No, you have to,
you have to be like over like I dunno,
60 I think at this point.
I think that because you've got
to realize like a lot of them,
like one of the guys like Ted nutrients
and under, they're in their sixties now,
so it's William Shatner
just turned 80 yeah,
the fuck man.
That real freaks me out when someone,
you know what I say so many things
in the podcasts that people tell me.
What about you can't be real. No, no, no.
He's like 70 he was, he was like 35 when
he did it. How do you spell his name?
William Wallace. A. H. A.
T. N. E. R, maybe not an s.
H Shatner. Yeah, Shah. S. H.
A. T in the year maybe. Okay.
What's truly exposing?
How stupid we are not done.
You can beat people and still be
successful in Showbiz. Yeah. It's amazing.
You could be so stupid
and yet still make it.
I remember an agent one time telling
me he gets, you've got some comedian,
some huge gigs, some huge
big money playing gay cause
this guy was kind of, no,
it's true.
He was born in 1931 that is fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
What makes sense?
Because the star trek was in the
60s so he was thirties thirties.
Well he was kind of sucking in his
gut with that little tidy 30 seconds,
go a little bit. And then they were, they
were walking a wig with him back then.
I don't know. He still had his hair. Wow.
That's so weird. Ah, I don't know. Yeah,
it was like, it was just going. But he's
got parents. Fuck right plugs though.
Cause you could never really look like
you don't thinks that's not plugs. Oh,
what did he get? Oh, it's a toupee.
Yeah. Yeah. That's a, that's a set.
Pay as a wig. Whatever. He's cool as
fuck. I let them get away with it.
Those old guys,
like you ever see like Humphrey bogarts
wig than he used to wear back in the day.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Pretty obvious one.
Yeah. I'm free. Bogart was going
bald as he was a movie star.
They got him a fucking wig.
Frankly. Jesus Christ, you know. So
I have watched a bunch of his movies,
man. Honestly, bro Grind. I saw a lot of
Frank Sinatra and I know frank liked him.
Frank took a lot of his swagger
from that guy nearly. Yeah. Yeah.
If you watch those movies.
Yeah. Yeah. He's got a couple
man, he's got one. I can't,
I'm so bad at remembering
the names of movies.
He's got one where he calls this girl
out on some female shit that like,
you know, I saw it. I was like,
that shit happened to me last week.
Just totally calls her out when she tried
to change the subject about something
and it was, it was just, it was awesome.
Say That's not what we were talking about.
Naw, he, but he wasn't back. This story
he had that he didn't know that was,
what was it like Edward G.
Robinson?
Shitty accent. So w w was it like
hit no, his, he had just more,
I can't do an impression of the guy,
but he had just more of a laid back.
He just would,
she just would be sitting in a scene
looking at you and you just immediately
felt like,
oh shit.
Movies where the guy would get mad, he
would fucking smack the check. Yeah,
that's what they used to do. I think they
did it on Archie bunker, didn't they?
They would never consider it watch.
She didn't, Archie hit Eden's.
She got really mad at him I think so she
was really upset. I remember that Shit.
I just sort of vaguely remembers you.
We're not making this up.
I think I remember that too.
I think there was so long ago that's,
that's tricky. Wanted it to happen.
You know you're home.
Every cell in your body except your
neurons gets replaced every seven years.
So your memory, where the fuck is you
memory stored? Is it in your brain?
Is it in your neurons? Is it
nonlocal? Nobody really knows.
So when you look back on a memory
that you had from like 20 years ago,
who knows what the fuck,
whether you've made that up on the story
of a memory that you use to remember
and he created something new.
You know who lived in,
no,
I know what you're saying because I've
listened to guys tell stories about stuff
where I was there. And I was just like,
I don't remember it like it. Yeah.
Well people were, remember the
guy in the sale, people, you know,
we want our living room.
Are you talking about no brow.
We just won the lottery.
You don't remember
just came back from a
banding on a Ustream. Um,
I was banned yesterday for throw.
Showing a phone. Showing a thong. Yeah.
What? Yeah, this girl, uh,
we had on peaches and we
also had the holidays of all,
what, what'd you say her name
was peaches. I know one peaches.
That it was her real name. She was
a wardrobe person on a fear factor.
Very nice lady. Right. That was a real
name. What's this girl's real names?
This girl Sarah Peaches.
And the reason we were asking why
she was called peaches cause there,
but it looks like a peach. And so we're
like, oh, we got to see this button now.
So she pulled down her pants and
she had a thong on. Uh, and uh,
I guess people complained and they
just banned my whole account. But,
but I thought they,
the Ustream just hooked you up and just
said that you were going to get oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. But that
doesn't, there's that there's
a difference between, uh, like, you
know, standards and practices. Exactly.
So did you contact the guy contacted him,
they pulled the video and then put me
back up and they're just saying that,
you know, nowadays it's kind of like a
network TV. They have sponsors, you know,
you can't, you can't have certain things.
But that's what I thought I was like,
thongs though are like you can go
on the beach with a Thong, right?
Yeah. I mean, what two? You like
country music, right? And that work,
I'm sure. Like you couldn't show a
thong on that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So the broadcast network, so I guess,
you know, it's all new technology.
It's all new shit. So kind of had
to find the Bordeaux, we talk about,
well we talk about it as a fucking
thousand times more light. Absolutely.
All a thong. That's it.
Really. Yeah. So fucking weird.
Like what you were saying
about that, the, you know,
the situation that happened when you
were doing that show and you know,
people get offended. And
what was the, was the one,
what was the story that was in the
news while you're doing the show?
Don Imus with Donna. I'm a store. Would
you call the girls nappy headed hoes?
When I was doing the man show, it
was um, Janet Jackson's nipple.
Janet Jackson's nipple in the Superbowl
came out right while we were doing the
man show. And I thought, Oh, what
the fuck? It's nothing. You know,
what is this stupid stunt,
you know, but Dee, who cares
really? I mean to me it was,
it was a nonissue,
but it became this fucking huge thing
in show business where you could,
I mean they came in and
changed monologues. They
came in and cut out scenes.
They cut out, cut out sketches. They were
like, no more, we can't, we can't do this.
We're going to have to take this way back.
Could be on the phone call when it comes
from whatever group or Washington DC.
When they say that I, I think it's, it's,
it's because that they actually
take it seriously. Yeah.
It's just so disappointing though.
When you see all these fucking people
scrambled because some chick pulled out
her nipple and the crazy thing
was the news, the big thing,
and the paper said that it was during
the dinner hour. That's what it said.
I totally blocked it.
People will write to be amended.
It was on network television.
All right. It was the super bowl.
You got your kids watching.
I understood.
What could I have kids are you raising
that are going to be freaking out about a
chicks nipple? Siri, yeah.
Wait, no, wait a minute. Wait,
and when you still want your
kids to have a child that,
that's what I think about Nipples,
a smelling months. That's a little bit
bit of excitement in their childhood.
It's not like fucking Janet Jackson
and starts stroking the nipple and,
and fingering or I'll tell you what,
man is whip out a black
tent in front of my kids.
They're going to start laughing at you.
I don't think it's funny. Well listen.
Okay, because people out there, they
have how they want to raise their kids.
So it's like they don't have cable,
so keep all the smite on cable
and I should be able to be here.
So that thing crossed in, I would,
you know what I compared it to,
it was like a orange juice and brushing
your teeth individually, they were fine,
but you bring them together.
It's back.
There's nothing wrong with seeing
an iconic good point, iconic titty.
But you had it on network TV and that was,
that was the problem.
So that's an interesting
way to look at it. Yeah.
I think we're way too hung up about
sex though. I think that's a nonissue.
I really do. It's not like they
were fucking on TV. If they,
if she pulled out her pussy and fingered
herself in front of the camera and go,
yeah, you just went too far.
Now you're all sexual. It's
a football game. Yeah. Yeah.
But they're doing some sexual
performance network television.
We watch dancing with the stars. They're
fucking on the stage. I mean the,
the lumbar on each other and when the
woman will straddle the guy's cock,
what's going on there? But you're, you're
imitating some songs for sexuality. Yeah.
But this is the thing, you
know that okay. Football,
the kid doesn't know that.
Know what I'm saying is as a parent,
if you've decided to watch
dancing with the stars,
if you're going to watch a football game,
you're not expecting to see a titty.
So you just expect to see dudes that weigh
300 pounds of jacked up with Anna and
human growth hormone running at each
other and smashing into each other. Yeah.
And somehow or another,
a tit is scarier than that.
I'm not saying I have a problem
with it. I'm saying, look,
you have to understand I'm not either,
I'm just does a fake argument, bro.
I'm just try to keep this going. All
right. People are fucking roll with it.
Like you just fucking like,
just like you got to respect that
other people don't aren't, you know,
I told, I told her, I go, look, I want
my kid to have like, dude, you know,
even if it was like one second,
I don't even know what a pussy
looked like until I was like, what?
Like 12 should I grew up with
me, you know, I want to show you,
we're talking about one second by the way,
I'm just saying I was allowed to have a
fucking childhood and be innocent for a
little bit.
But like now it's just like the shit that
you can get away with on like network
TV now because of cable is fucking,
I remember like the,
when the Benny Hill show came out,
people are freaking out. He was doing,
he was walking up behind girls acids
pretending he was warming his hands and
you'd had that silly and Wayne Antica
Dante's walking in fast motion and they
were freaking out.
And I sat there as like a fucking like
seven year old turned on by it because
the that was like to bait was
the Benny Hill show back then.
And I think that like, seriously,
I don't think that it's that,
I think kids do see way too much.
I don't think that you
should be embarrassed about
bodies and stuff like that.
But I mean,
dude,
you want to understand they can go
into your laptop and like we didn't,
we couldn't,
you couldn't see any light.
I got porno when we were coming up here
to have to have a fucking night at work,
a reel to reel,
and then it became VCR and then you'd
have to find your parents stash.
Now you can just go on the damn laptop.
I really sound like some, right? No,
but you're right,
you're right.
I'm just everything that they're going
to raise their kids the way they want to
raise him.
So if you chose not to have cable and
you want to stay away from that shit,
then it's fine.
I see what you're saying.
But the way I look at it as everything
accelerates and including access to
things, access to information, access
to even bad things. And you know, the,
the kids are gonna have to deal
with an ever changing world.
And if you went from where you were when
you were 12 to how you see the world
now, it'd be a pretty big fucking
shock, you know? And I think for kids,
it's like they're, they're going
to get it way earlier than did,
but that's just the nature of the world
today. It's kind of fight against that.
I don't think it's kind of like how
the started off as such slow speeds.
They get 56 k modem for top four and he
used to be like, Hey, what's this photo?
Oh Hey, oh, that's a horse's stick. Oh my
God, what's going on in that person's ass?
You know,
you kind of were diluted to the Internet
because you did this slowly as it was a
slow process of all this disgusting
Shit route on the Internet where people
watch that type of shit or they
watch like, uh, beheadings oh no, no.
I mean I'm talking about sending you
things or you're not going to do really
fucked up.
There's a lot of people who aren't on the
vice squad but have like that level of
mental damage in there like an accountant
because they go on and watch somebody
get their head sought off.
Like I remember that video and like
comics come in and go on yet. Dude,
I shouldn't have watched say like
you saw like I've got a bit my echo.
I talk about you Sol.
I view it like it's pixelated and
every time you see something that you
shouldn't have seen,
like a couple of cubes float away and
you get just never the same person. So I,
I think, I don't know, I'm trying, I'm
trying to like watching porn is though.
Yeah. Yeah. I just, I tried to do
that when I started having kids,
but stop watching porn. You started
thinking about those kids, you know,
stars and you've got the Watson anymore.
It's like a tipping point.
There's a tipping point with this shit
where it's kind of like, all right,
this is healthy.
You're exploring what you're into and
then you just go down a rabbit hole,
you closes behind you and uh,
easily you can easily go down.
How many guys do we know that have been
addicted to masturbating when they talk
about live masturbate in three times a
day, every day. Even if they're not hard,
you know, they just keep
going. See what I mean?
[inaudible] get a guy a lot of free times.
Shag rug here.
You give guys enough free time there.
They're going to drug off just the
fact totally. They do it in prison.
Even though people know
people are watching.
They don't care who's guys in
solitary confinement there.
Naked beaten off with a camera on him.
Just do it on that,
on that podcast with that chick
with the Sarah Peaches. Uh,
the guy that came with her
was the Hollywood sex, uh,
like anyone that has a sex tape,
they go to him to sell it and stuff.
He did a Paris Hilton's and he was
talking about how no, she was behind that.
She made about $7 million from that shit.
And like,
like he just fucking broke through.
Like all these people like that have
come up to him like, he's like, yeah,
I have a Lindsay Lohan one,
but it's from the back,
so I can't verify if it's herb.
It's supposedly,
it really is her giving a blow job.
And how crazy is it that these people
figured out a way to make money and get
famous off of porn? Yeah,
I was in dash was in, yeah,
I was in Australia and there was a fucking
giant Kim Kardashian poster and all I
can think of that girl got famous
for fucking a guy on film. I mean,
she's a porno star,
you know,
I mean fucking the film that they used
to ruin your career now makes something
out of nothing. I'm going, I should really
shouldn't throw a name out here by it.
Was it Jane Kennedy?
You guys don't watch sports.
There was this girl back in the day.
She was on the NFL on CBS and uh,
her ex boyfriend sent out a tape,
a sex tape after they broke up a,
of her getting fisted, I believe.
Oh my goodness. The general public didn't
see it because there was no youtube,
none of that. It just went around the
industry. That was the end of her career.
Wow. Yeah. You can't get fisted. Yeah.
And now nowadays, yeah. Like
that would actually, you know,
you know that that would be part of
like your, your imdv page, you know,
if they will try and see how much
money she get paid for a pilot.
Well he's done already two pilots.
He's done a Letterman, you know, we uh,
Bang this girl and fucking came on her
face so you know, his dick is out there.
Definitely has some sort of
cue ration, you know, ratio,
whatever the fuck you say.
Well she has two fists things
online. Actually, wait a minute,
why am I saying I've got a guy
can't get away with that shit.
Like think like females
can make like a sex tape.
Certain ones can have it sex tapes before
and I'm going to Tom Sizemore and one
or the Tom Sizemore one, but he didn't
blow up after that. That was part of that.
We're still awesome. It's
still awesome. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I know what he said,
that he has a tape right now with
usher that he's like getting sued for
something like that and
he's getting pegged in it.
And I didn't know what pegged means,
but uh, whoa. Wait a minute. Ushers Gay.
Wait a minute. You don't like peg means,
I don't know, zooming in the, but it's,
it's where a girl wears a
Dildo and fucks you in the ass.
Why listen to the podcasts. It's
crazy. Uh, it's not as show number 12.
I going to get sued. Yeah. Yeah. You
can't say he said, I didn't say it.
All right on. I will say allegedly,
but that's what he said. Funny.
That is so common that guys like
girls fuck them would strap ons.
They have a nickname for it pegged
and everybody's like, oh yeah,
hey does that before? Oh yeah. Oh,
I'm well aware of what that entails.
What a fucking crazy business. It
was a, this, this guy that I know,
his buddy was dating a porn star and he
was dealing with it for awhile because
he was kind of a loser.
He didn't have a job and you know,
didn't really have much going on.
She would like pay for dinner and stuff
like that. And you know, he just said, ah,
it's just work for her. It's
work for her. She just work.
One day he comes home and she's going
over her contract for our next thing and
uh, and he goes, what is air tight mean?
That's like one of the descriptions of
scenes. It means a dick and every hole.
And she goes, one of my mouth, what am
I? But when I post it, I'm out. He goes,
that's it. I'm out. He got up. That
was the end of the relationship.
He packed up his shit and he moved
out. Fucking them. Done what?
Air Tight. Like this bitch
wasn't just doing porn, you know,
he tried to distance himself and
not watch any of it. You know,
it just kind of a liberal fellow and
I'm trying to create this man air tight.
I like this,
but it was just,
it's so common that girls know what it
means when it's in the, in your contract,
you have to do one air tight.
You know, one cream pie,
they'll think it's funny that they still
have to come up with these euphemisms
because even with them they try and make
it so you know, we're gonna, you know,
start off with the standard or do you
know Blah Blah Blah and we'll build to an
airtight and do a facial sounds
like a spa. Well some of them,
some of them are so common that
it's actually with the search terms,
like cream pie cream pie is you shoot a
load inside a girl and then she kind of
squirts
it out like a, like a cream pie.
I'm familiar with the porn. Yeah,
but I mean what the fuck
man? Yeah, everyone, it's so
common that it's a category.
Like if you go to like youporn
or something like that,
that's one of the
categories is cream pies,
shooting loads and girls like hello
diseases here have a disease in your butt.
But that's, that's what I, I don't get
that in there, but I don't get like a,
I know they get tested all the time.
What does that mean?
Those guys are fucking heroin
junkies every night. You know,
who knows what they're doing. You take,
they get tested like every three months,
you know, like that doesn't mean
anything. That's crazy. I don't know.
I don't know how good it is now,
but I remember back in the day, man,
when they way of scaring the shit out
of every straight guy out there that
you're gonna get aids.
Yeah. They said that uh,
the fuck doesn't mean the safest
way. Oh yeah. Do you remember that?
Like back in the day you get, when did,
what year did you take an aids test?
When I took one was 96 or
seven and I remember I had to,
you had to wait like five,
six days.
It's one thing walking about walking
around worrying because they had everybody
worried that they had it.
So worrying that you had,
it was something that you give out,
you know,
but knowing that you are
going to find out in fact,
actually one way or
the other in five days.
But fortunately I had
a really cool doctor.
I was sitting there in the waiting room
just like just rocking back and forth on
why did I bang that shit? Jesus Christ so
fucking weak. Why did I give it to her?
Right. And he came walking up and he was
really cool. He said, Mr. Byrd combined.
He said, come on back. And he
goes, don't worry, you're all set.
Like he said it in the waiting room.
He didn't,
he didn't let me take that long walk,
like the next Douche bag. Like I,
I would like I,
the only time I would get tested
would be like if I was getting into a
relationship and basically the girl said,
we need to go out and get tested for
everything. And I was like, yeah,
let's be responsible.
Well, and I was like, fuck the
guy taking my test. I took,
I had to get insurance when I first moved
to New York because it was like 90 91
that's why I took my first test and
the guy who was testing me, he said,
have you ever had gay sex? No. Have
you ever shared a needle? No. He goes,
you don't have nothing to worry
about. I'm like, really? Really goes,
you got nothing to worry about it. He
goes, trust me, you're going to be okay.
And I'm like, this guy's just being
nice to me. Manage just being nice.
And you just think about all those girls.
I should've wore a condom with the fuck
was I thinking and what does that mean?
I should have wore a condom if you knew
she had aids or would you stick your
dick inside of her with a little tiny
thin little membrane protecting you from
the depths of hell? No, you wouldn't.
You know, it's fucking craziness. But uh,
I,
I went and the guy did the same thing.
He called me up and he gave
me the results over the phone.
And as he called me up, he goes,
Joe, you're all set. You're all set.
I just want to relax. Nope,
totally negative. No problem. Yeah.
But for fucking days are
shitting my pants. Convinced,
convinced I added like a red shirt.
Virgin.
What do you get to think about that
and how much knowledge that we have,
what we really know the average person
knows about medical science and think
about what it must've been like when
medical science didn't exist and you
thought you really were cursed.
You know the shit probably worked.
You know you could probably car someone
with witchcraft and they probably would
fucking trip every way they go and fall
and land on their fucking face and break
their neck
and I dodged. That happens. That's like
when say bad things come in threes.
It's no,
you keep restarting counting after three.
That's what happens when people go off
this, do this, and then this is like, yes,
that makes four. If you count back
to the beginning of your life,
you now is it divisible by three?
It's like it's life. Bad Shit happens.
Good Cycle. Whenever his celebrity dies,
they would say, you know, dead straight.
They're all comes from,
this is a thing though.
Even jokes when you described jokes,
they'd come in through the best
way to tell a joke. I have. Yeah.
I usually have three, three examples
that are ridiculous. I know that's true.
I'm just talking about the bad she'll,
why is that though that things in three
celebrities dies in celebrities dying in
three they don't. People recount after
three if they went one right there.
We're talking about a small period in
time. It's not like time is open ended.
They're talking about over a
course of all your couple of weeks,
three very famous people will die and
it happens all the time. It really does.
It really doesn't know that people just
stopped counting at three and then I
just start over again.
I could say let somebody would die like
two days later and it doesn't count.
It all dies like a month later.
Then they go, okay, that's one.
You wait and you wait.
It's like, yeah, I guess
celebrities probably don't count because
fucking there's a billion people over
there. They must be dropping
off every day. Yeah, there's,
I'm sure there's famous
country singers to you.
That would have been like the biggest
star ever. Where other who me,
I don't even know who that guy is.
Wrap your fucking head around the fact
that China has more than three times the
people that America has. Yeah.
More than three times. What's up?
People shitting on the side of the road.
I said to on the podcast that they
will self sustainable that they uh,
but apparently they're not anymore.
Apparently now they're,
they're important grain people got
upset at me so no, I guess they'd not,
but you know what I want
to hear about pouring rain.
I always wonder like how
am I wonder if that's,
I wonder if they're forced to do that one.
If they're forced to buy like American
grain and we sell them grain and you know,
well if you want to read a great article
is the one in rolling stone this month
that has Howard stern on the cover is
they talk about these two basically
potheads who became these international
arms dealers and just how that whole
thing goes down.
How boundaries when they want to arm a
certain side and some smaller country,
but they don't want the shit coming
back to them. How they go about it,
how they go through these people.
There's to some website, uh, uh,
Christ, what the hell
is it? I can't remember,
but it's like the military is required
to put all their contracts on it so you
can read all their contracts.
This is typical,
may something interesting and I can't
tell you where to go to and you can read
all their contracts and
they're open to any bitter.
I think during the Bush administration
they made it like that, you know,
so I dunno, free enterprise.
I don't know why,
but it kind of seemed like it was a
way for them to then arm certain people
without it coming back.
It's like we basically have another people
do your dirty work, but just the way,
well that's what the hard
idea about mercenaries is. I mean that's
what the big complaint about what,
you know,
blackwater and those types of groups
is that we use them overseas and it's
basically a way to get away
with doing like really dirty.
Oh yeah, totally thing. I mean,
this is the, how I look at it.
Everybody does it and I don't
know what their end game. Right.
But she's been doing it.
I mean [inaudible]
if we are what we pretend we are,
then we should be the ones who
stand up and say that this is, well,
this is what you can't do. You can't
torture prisoners. You can't, you can't.
Absolutely.
Do you think we can do
that in a country that uh,
actually sticks by what we say we are?
Because everybody
seems that someone has to
lead an example, right? We do.
We say the world's filled with line
con, so we're going to be lying. Cons,
I don't know. I mean, I see
what you're saying. I see
the other argument that like,
look,
the world's a dirty place and you're going
to have people that are willing to do
your bidding. No. You know, like,
yeah, no, I'm going to ask. Yeah.
I don't get how war is legal and I don't
get how like Jesus freaks and really
religious people get behind war.
They've been doing it for like the
acquisitions and the, and the Crusades.
They were taking murderers
out of prison going,
you are forgiven and then unleashing
them and like the Middle East to do what
you,
the reason why you stuck it behind bars
but they just don't want it for them.
Church, did they really? Yeah.
When? What year was this?
That's just some fucking website.
I've read it off for three minutes.
One of the reasons why I wanted
to have presented as fact,
I mean I always loved
my son talking to you,
but I know that you're one of those guys
that doesn't believe anything in the
news is what it is and
these motherfuckers,
so that's why I wanted to talk to you
about all this shit that's going on in the
Middle East. It's like every fucking day
some new government is being overthrown.
It's, it's getting really weird
to the point where I'm like, man,
they both like fucking prepping for
something. Like what is going down? Why?
How's that?
Is it really what everybody says it is
that all the sudden with the Internet,
people are becoming aware
and they're all rising up.
It takes more than just being aware to
get people to risk their fucking lives
and get, I mean, in Libya,
this is motherfuckers flying jets and
launching missiles in the crowds and shit.
He's killing people. They're shooting
right into crowd. Might not be with jets,
but I might've made that up,
but I know they're shooting into crowns
and killing people left and right and
like these people that
are fighting against him.
Yeah. There's a movement that's going
on. I don't know what it is, but it was,
you know, no, the real fear.
There's guys out there who we put in
power and we were cool with and then when
they stopped being cool with us,
then we go in and we try to take them off.
I'll tell you,
you know what's really fucked up where
those celebrities who went out and they
did like a corporate gig for like Kadafi
these kids. Yeah. They try to act like,
oh, I didn't know. It's like, dude,
if you work at a comedy club and
there's somebody like in a wheelchair,
the club owner comes back, hey,
not telling you how to do your act.
Just to let you know that someone in
the crowd, the wheelchair. So I mean,
you know.
Yeah.
Is she aware of that show that you close
with? You might want to not use it.
So these people are going to perform
for the kids. Have a mass murderer.
Don't you think they get some sort of
halftime speeds? Listen, don't say this.
You don't want offend their cult. Just
letting them know, like I had no idea.
I was really disappointed when I saw it
are formed for Gaddafi. Uh, what was it?
A Beyonce usher, Mariah Carey.
And then they all just sit.
Then they all donated it to charity, but
only cause they got busted Kadafi pegs.
That's what I heard.
Gadhafi pays a peg eggs. Are
you just making shit up? Oh,
they're asking people if they should,
uh, give their, uh, their money back.
Apparently there's a lot.
Yeah, be onsite. Did it? Huh?
Yeah. And I saw this photo and
it's like, dude, it's hilarious.
It's like you got somebody who can sell
out the fucking staple center. It's like,
why you do,
you really got to go there and entertain.
That's scumbag cause it just so
much money. Like what do they all,
they pay for like a million million
bucks for like a night and you come.
There was funny.
Was that one of the pictures I saw now,
I don't know if this was actually
her at the Gig, but dude,
it's like she's standing out in your
living room going full out doing fucking
routines. Be Awesome for the kid
of a murder of, of a mass murder.
The guy who admittedly is buying
those pan-am bombings. Right. Wow.
My crazy thinking that that
killed Americans and that
kid has a musical. Yeah, no,
he is the [inaudible] rig on it.
Dancing like literally dancing
dance for me. Let's go.
And that kid is my backup.
Oh, oh, oh, oh yeah.
Oh sure.
Apparently performed for him to the bow.
He gave a Beyonce $2 million
for her private performance.
Whoa. That's pretty crazy. His youngest
son Hannibal. That's his fucking son.
After the silence of the
lambs, if you name your kid
Hannibal, you're a sick fuck.
Yeah,
and it wasn't even a nickname.
He knew coming out of the woods yet his
kid was going to be a sick. Fuck you.
So nothing is scarier than
the sons of dictators.
You ever hear about what is the Udi and
Qusay or whatever the fuck Saddam's kids
wrote all the shit they
did. They fed women to dogs.
They did. They did horrible.
Should they do,
they were fine women.
One of the things we would do is find
a woman as she was getting married,
they would find her like as like
you literally go into the wedding,
kill the husband in front of everybody.
I take the wife raper and
killer and feeder the dogs is,
they used to grind people
up in meat grinders.
Like some of those
stores are just horrific.
I mean they grew up with Ryan and Mikko.
What's what sort of,
how big was the MC when they're alive?
I don't know who. Who Will? Ha Ha. Well,
you can easily stick someone in the wood
chipper if you want it to. Oh yeah, no,
I understand that. That would be easy.
Guys fall into woodchippers all the time.
I saw,
I saw a guy get busted.
They figured out that he did it and then
they just went out on his property and
he just had like, you know,
basically human bone shrapnel.
Oh, I love this part of the Oliver,
the part of the woods. Dude,
I was on a key recently and
this guy, you know, who is, uh,
allegedly a federal agent, but if by
the end of it, I didn't even believe,
and he was telling me all these horrific
stories and I'm sitting there looking
at the guy,
first of all,
when he walked in on of the first things
he did was he picked his nose and I'm
like,
and I had already shook his hand,
like a fucking segway who
doesn't pick their nose?
Then he adjusts his Dick and at one point
he's in the middle of telling me about
being on a stakeout.
He starts digging in his ass to the point.
It's like almost on his tip toes.
He's like fucking dude. And he's like,
and you could tell he was like habitually
picking his ass because he's in the
middle of talking to me. He just
met me and he said, yeah, you know,
so standing out there and we have
fucking sounds going like this.
I'm looking at and he's going, yeah,
I'm a federal agent. It's like, Dude,
you're picking your ass.
And also why you telling me all this shit?
It's Kinda like the guys who go to
war and they actually see some shit,
never talk about it. And then the guy
who's fucking working in the kitchen,
oh yeah, man, shit was crazy. I
shot this guy in the fucking head.
That's after awhile. I was like,
I think this guy is like this.
Did you see these new photos
that came out from Afghanistan?
They're basically just like the,
um, the, what was the fucking,
the prison was the prison
where a Guantanamo? No, no, no.
Well the one where they took all those
photos of all the Iraqi's and did all
that fucked up shit in the soldiers did.
I can't remember too long ago. Brian,
do you remember? No. You
don't know what it is.
You don't even know what the
story is anyway. These, um,
there's new photos to just
surfaced and they're, uh,
they're just like those photos. What
the fuck was the name of the, uh, yeah,
but is that shocking you, you really don't
want to get captured by the enemy? No.
Yeah, it's pretty fucked up. The Oem,
they won't be there smiling like holding
people up by the hair and like look,
Aba grave. Thank you. Bobby Walton
42. Mr. Alex Walton. You've,
you got it for me bunny. They Aba
grape, you know, and they, uh,
they were doing the same sort of
shit and one of them was a fence.
Family friends with Sarah
Pailin for like 20 years.
It's fucking holding up this guy by his
hair. Bullet holes in them and shit.
I'll have to, he's dead. Yeah. Yeah.
The definition. I gotta
admit, if I was over there,
I'd be doing that shit with you.
How many people can you shoot in the head
before you don't get a little twisted?
You've got to find the comedy in it.
Well, the crazy thing is I was fucking
poor. Kids are coming back, you know,
and you meet him,
you know.
[inaudible] they kind of cocked a
squelch that, by the way. But yeah.
Well at one point in time,
more people had died in one month
in suicides than had died in combat.
I mean, it's, it's scary shit. You know
the number, the ratio for the month.
I, yeah, I mean,
you're not supposed to kill another
human pig if it goes against the, uh,
I don't know. Especially somebody you
don't even know, you know. All right.
It's okay if you know him. No, I
mean, pinup killing someone for,
you know,
you just get told this is a bad person.
Go over there and kill them and you're
over there going, what the fuck?
I flew to their neighborhood,
I landed and I snuck into their backyard
and I shot them in the fucking head.
Yeah.
If I think if I ever went to war,
I would be the guy crying in
the foxhole during battle.
But if I could somehow muster up the balls
to kill somebody after I did that one,
it would be like a fucking water slide.
I mentally would just get used to it.
Now that and know, it's like I just
know how my brain works. It's why,
you know I had, I had some buddies
of mine who will, who have, you know,
go down to Brazil and banging those
girls and doing that. And it's just like,
and I never went and they, you know,
wow. Why don't you go? It's like,
cause I'll go down there, I'll come back,
but mentally you'll be fucked, dude.
I can't go to a land where I can go.
Yeah,
well you can go fuck a bunch
of j Lo's for like eight bucks.
Come back here and think that
I can function in society.
That's what those x patch and we
need to sit down and talk about
this. Lately I'd be like, shut up.
Fuck j Lo for $8 you can get on a plane.
It's six hours. I can, I
can as many as I wanted.
I know that you can bring her back here.
You could go stealer,
bring her back here.
Yeah. I mean it's evil.
If you are willing to deal with something.
I don't want to fly to the third world
and fuck the children of some of the
poorest people on the planet for
like DVD money after my shows.
It's just something, you know,
not to say I'm not a twisted fuck.
I think it's cause I
know how twisted I am.
I try to like stay away from that shit.
I'm the same way.
I think there's a certain,
well I think everybody's a comic cause
a little bit of a side girl, you know,
just to the act of going on stage,
demanding that kind of attention.
Lit Microphone, voice, the whole
deal. I woke up the other day,
I had an argument with a girl I went
out with 15 years ago about what about,
I asked you, it's a long fucking
store. Just some bullshit.
She did something stupid. She
did something stupid. All right.
And I wanted to be like,
I was trying and she fucked up in
her life and she fucked up so bad.
I was actually scared going,
how am I going to pick her up off the mat
because I know if I did some shit like
that, I'll be thinking about
kill me. She fucked up.
So I'm trying to build her up and the
whole time of more specific emotions now,
she just goes, I know. I know.
She kept gone. I know, I know.
I just maybe being so fucking people
like, you know what? You don't know.
You're a fucking moron, but you did you
arrogant pig headed it just, it just,
she have a nice house. Yeah. So
I woke up and that's what I was,
my eyes weren't even what weren't
even open. I was laying in a,
in a fucking hotel yelling at it with my
eyes closed and then sort of knowing in
my head how fucked up that is.
How long ago was this argument
that you had with her? Like I said,
it was like 15 years or so by yourself.
You're in a hotel room, you wake up,
your eyes aren't even open and you go
like, you fucking dummy. I told you.
Yeah, that's crazy. You need. I bet.
I bet. Been need a cat scan home.
I've been to one, I got one.
Uh, whenever I do Letterman,
I always have a nightmare than I that I,
that I bombed.
But I've been through enough times and
I always do well, so I know I'm fine.
I thought you were going to say, whenever
I do Letterman, I always get a cat scan.
No, no, no. So last time I did
it, I was having those thoughts.
They woke me up in the middle of the night
and I actually started talking to the
voices. I just said, oh, shut the
fuck up. It's going to be fine.
And I went back to sleep.
Well sometimes it's a good thing to
do to actually have conversations with
yourself, I think. I think you have to
be aware that you're a psycho. That's,
that's step one. And then just you,
you know, you, if you're a psycho,
you're a fight. You can't be cured
of being a psycho. You just have, oh,
that's not true.
You evolve to put show on showtime
where he only kills the bad people.
Dexter Dexter. Yeah. It's like
Dexter. No, you evolve, you evolve,
you texters time. You recognize what
you're doing wrong with your life.
You understand what makes you feel shitty,
what you feel good and you have
all that happened. That's for it for me.
I'm joking. You don't want it anymore.
So this shit is a deck. The
coconut water, it's the shit,
that little burst of energy and
then you want some more. You're,
you're all fired up. You look at fight
one of your brothers right now. Fun, Fun,
fun, fun, fun. Yeah.
Have you heard this fucking song and I
talked about it to you before we started.
You haven't heard it.
It's a song bed.
So the by a 13 year old girl and they
were talking about it on Opie and Anthony.
I had already heard it, but I didn't
know the story behind it. And uh, uh,
opie and Anthony were saying
that apparently this girl,
13 or dad has a lot of money and they
produced a song for her and it's fucking
Rudel this pork kid,
first of all,
there's like 34 million hits in Youtube.
And when I watched it the other day,
it was only a couple of days ago,
there was only 24 million,
so 10 million fucking hands in a
couple of days just because it's awful.
That's how awful it is. And can
people's lives are awful. Yeah,
but may want to see somebody fail.
They do, but it's also the [inaudible].
I want to see it do. What the fuck
is that thing? That's an iPad.
Check this. I'm so far behind in the
times. That's like in the future.
This is the worst time in the
history of the world. And by the way,
if I was 13 my song
would be worse than this.
So I'm not judging when I was 13 my
song and be a hundred times worse.
7:00 AM waking up in the morning.
I love it to you.
She's like dead ends.
Listen to the lyrics.
Mommy's calling, checking on and
on. Everybody's machine dance.
You got to catch my breath
and my friend
got,
I made my mind up.
Which seat can I take?
It gets worse.
Okay, what the fuck, Bro? No, no, no.
That's fine. I don't want to hear anymore.
What is that? You getting emails? Yeah.
That was a twit. Come on, don't, don't,
I don't want your fucking thing
off and this is gets better.
I want billboard to Berta. Freak out.
He's freaking out right now. See Him?
It gets worse.
Marty Party,
party
fun.
[inaudible]
German on that week.
Alright. Shut it off. Oh No, no, no, no.
You have to ask to see the part where
it spells it out and writes out what the
words are. No, don't tell
them. Let them experience this.
Am I writing this?
You got now,
you know,
kicking in and the fried chicken
back. See how the fuck are they driving
at 13 that's what I want to know.
Or is she hanging around with 17
year olds that are fucking her
gets worse. Come, come, come, come, come.
By the way, this shit is going to be stuck
in your head that Friday. Friday. Yeah.
[inaudible] here we go.
Picked up the music underneath it.
It's already in party and yeah,
fine.
Give me goes.
This is the best part.
[inaudible] date is Friday.
April.
We know if we tell him
Saturday
and Sundays comes out,
do you know who she's failing?
She's somebody runs over that 50 Tyson.
Have you heard from 50 survey know
who is this black guy? Oh, I know.
At first I thought it was
like somebody that's famous.
The fuck is this fascinating.
Switching the names where the cough my
side [inaudible] some black dude with a
big watch. He must be the producers like,
yo Yo make this video. Let me let it out.
But I got to get into some fucking
horrible cancer saying his runner through
auto tune.
And then you had the black guy do the
guest set to give it some sort of,
I wouldn't say more. I would say 13
year old little girl, but yes, y'all,
she's got a peg now.
Her name is Rebecca Black.
That's the than the name of this song.
She's going to blow up now and she's
the next [inaudible] got it guys.
Party party party and yeah,
I wanted,
I wanted to keep watching it because I,
I knew he was going to freak out. Have
you guys ever seen a MC a 50 Tyson? Yeah,
we're throwing up a little bit more
when we can. Friday, Friday, end
of the black eyes still there.
He lends street cred.
It gives her street cred.
The thing is that the traffic
isn't that bad compared to,
what are you talking about?
It's the one of the worst tracks
in the history of the music.
The music underneath that shit kills
birds. They played that in a, in a, in a,
in a modern sanctuary and butterflies
will fall from the music. That's, that's,
that's just the shit that's out there.
That's like everybody,
like hate Justin Bieber going,
what is happening? A new look.
It's like they've always had that guy,
that guy who's always been there all
the way because in the block kids on the
block. Yeah. Fucking David
Cassidy. Yeah. Um, you know,
was that kid who killed himself? Remember
Brian Frazier? Where you around for?
Brian Frazier. Randy Gibbs. Shag dancing.
Did he kill himself and he, you know,
he's fucking oh deed. But there
was somebody else, the uh, uh,
something about you saying about being a
teenager. Do you remember Brian Frazier?
Was he in your, around your
time in Boston. All right.
Who Do you wonder what happened to
him? He's a writer now. He's writing,
but he had, he went fucking nuts.
Wants about Bill Hicks. Like there's,
over the years there's been a few
guys that were big Bill Hicks.
The centers like ours is a big Bill
Hicks to center all. He says, yeah,
he says important things,
but you know, he's not funny.
Or he just says he's not funny. He doesn't
make me laugh. It never made me laugh.
And he like,
and the death of Bill Hicks,
it was really pretty funny on
his Facebook are he goes, um,
now that it's a bill Hicks,
his death in his honor and you know,
in seeking truth as he did,
I want to admit that he's not funny.
Show me one video where he was
funny and it's fucking, it's brutal,
but he's got a point. I was a big
Bill Hicks Fan, but he's got a point.
There's a lot of that stuff that's just
not funny, you know. And, um, our report,
what was my point with what we were
talking about before this Friday,
Friday
we lost fit in the backseat now Ben,
Ben,
Ben.
What was my fucking point?
God dammit,
we were talking about, I said she
was a whore. You said she's 13. Oh,
this is what it was.
Brian Frazier, Brian Frazier. Let's
write back. Brian Frazier was going nuts.
He's like, okay. Everybody says
he's fucking awesome. He goes,
he's making fun of new kids on the block
and making fun of live pop, pop culture.
He goes, that's what's important. Pop
Culture. Who started going fucking crazy?
And I'm like, yeah, this kind of a silly
thing to get all upset about. You know,
he's doing like someone sucking
Satan's cock like a u was a Tiffany.
Tiffany was sucking Satan's cock and
he's like, Tiffany's a little girl.
She's a little girl.
Of course your songs suck.
You're not supposed to fucking listen
to him. And he starts going crazy.
And I'm like,
wow.
Right. That's right. I agree with,
look, he's right. But he's wrong.
But I'll know this is what I'll tell you.
This is why Sam Kinison is underrated.
Before he let fame consumer many days and
he did a special with fucking girls on
the ends of dog leashes. Do his
first specials. His first Letterman.
Yes. Still holds up. Yes.
Yes I am with you on matters.
And I say it all the time.
That is the test of how like
people go talk about comics now.
All this guy's this,
this guy's at,
you're not gonna know until 1520 years
later and then you go back and you listen
to this stuff.
Does it hold up?
You know Kinison and 86 was the
best comment that ever lived.
That's what I think the Kinison the came
out. There was never a guy like him.
There was never a guy who was
fuck [inaudible]
he had his own thing and this
rage and get in front of people.
She this parachute, it's phase. This is
marriage. Motherfucker just [inaudible].
There was nobody
[inaudible] what about,
but he had the ability to,
to reel it in and then unleash
it like preacher. Yeah.
Like a lot of guys who,
I've been guilty,
I've been on stage and you just feel
like Jesus, I just screamed for an hour.
That was bullshit. And I said, fuck too
many times they hit, bought him. He had a,
he had the ability, you know,
when he would bring it down? Yeah.
When he did that bit about like
necrophilia and when he's laying,
laying face down and he just goes,
okay, all right, so I'm dead. You know,
he's all the way down there
and then, oh, what is that?
You know how I found out about it? One
of the greatest tags ever. It never ends.
It never ends. One of the greatest
excuse fucking in the ass,
even after you're dead. It never
ends. But he, he, he, he, but he,
all of that was in just the line.
It never ends. Yeah. It's just fine.
I heard about that bit because I was
working at the Boston Athletic Club.
There was a girl who worked there and
she just got home from seeing the Hbo
Comedy Special With Sam Kennison and
she reenacted that bit in the fucking
parking lot of the club in South Boston.
She got on her stomach
and she goes, so I'm dead. I'm going
to be with Jesus. What is this?
It feels there's a deck in my head.
You mean live keeps fucking in the ass.
You've been after your dad had
never ran. Never had. Oh God.
Yeah and I was like,
that is the funny.
I was 19 and I remember thinking that
is the funniest fucking thing I've ever
heard in my life and
then I got a copy of it.
It was the first time I ever
thought I got in common.
This is sort of throw off bit that he did.
Why was this a CD after he had died,
they did like this compilation.
He did like the whole,
that whole bit on Captain Kangaroo,
which would normally be like a hacky bit,
but he got into the psyche of
the guy playing captain kangaroo.
This was the w later CD, right? Yeah.
This is like one of his last ones and
he was one of the things with that.
He decided not to put on and then he
dies and then somebody else puts it out.
It's one of those things,
it's kind of not fair.
Like a lot of the other material
wasn't, you know, up to snuff.
But he never released it. Don't
when he was alive. So I don't,
I don't criticize them for that,
but the uh,
the captain kangaroo bit through where
he gets into the psyche of the guy
talking about and he somehow he brings
it all around to s he was an out of work
actor. So he took the Gig and the, and the
end of the bit, he's yelling at his wife
go and we data the cash,
you know,
I didn't know that Gig was gonna last
20 fucking years and just screaming,
fucking haircut and
just the, the, the, the,
the horrific life of this guy.
Make somebody great. The ability,
anybody can be like a cat. The cat group,
let's up with this guy.
Like he got out and eat the whole
thing and just he turned the guy,
you saw the actor that played them,
which I grew up
watching him. And here's the
most important thing, and
this is where, I mean, again,
I'm a huge bill Hicks Fan.
I think what he did was brilliant and
he changed the way I looked at a lot of
things and he opened my eyes up to a
lot of things that were fascinating and
interesting but not necessarily funny.
And I would scream and cheer with it and
I would laugh along with it because I
agreed with it.
But you would see Kinison and he would
make a point that would fucking have you
doubled over with laughing.
And it's totally different.
Like there's a hicks bit that you can
find online about Hicks talking about he
wants his rock stars to have passion. It's
another one of these things, you know,
I want you to rock stars,
to go onstage and to unite everybody to
shoot yourself in the head and do heroin.
All is all these different things.
And he's screaming and yelling.
I want him to have passion.
But I'm looking at him
like, but where's the jokes?
Where's, where's the joke? Whereas
you watch a Kinison sketch,
especially the 86 Kennison like how about
the fucking thing about sending money
to the homeless, the poor kids
in Africa. And he goes, he goes,
don't send the money.
Send them a guy like me send.
My guy was going to go over there and go,
hey,
we just drove 3000 miles with
your food and it's realized, look,
we wouldn't have to do this if you'll
be able to live where they live in a
fucking desert.
Can you see that?
See that this is not going
to be a hundred years now.
We got deserts in America too.
We just don't live in a mass.
I know that word word fucking is the best.
He was based,
he's the guy.
He's the guy.
My Mount Rushmore's guy
would be prior Kinison. Uh,
Carlin. Yeah, I need like one
out of gangs is in there for me.
Pixels in there for me.
But Hicks
is in there in a different way.
He's like a brilliant social satirist.
Just say Martin Martin. Lawrence.
I'm tell you something, man,
don't discount Martin Lawrence Dude.
And then the Sunday see Martin Martin
Lawrence. Oh yes, for sure. Good point.
Steve Martin's a monster. The early Steve
Martin fucking, I wish he never stopped,
man. He was so good. Let's get
small. Actually, it's a brilliant,
especially Martin Lawrence because what
everybody else was doing at the time,
everyone was trying to do what I think
Carla was doing. Oh, what prior was doing?
And he just came out with a fucking
arrows between and was just being simply
guys. That's the thing too.
Like I love silly comedy. Yes.
I love that stupid shit.
Like not saying that his stuff was stupid,
but I liked that kind of stuff.
Uh, I like my stuff. Wait, silly.
My favorite stuff is my stuff. That's
silly. I mean, I like angry stuff,
but I like doing silly stuff.
Sometimes it's a function of Gio
has to wear the leather coat,
smoking the cigarette guy. Hey man,
you know, corporations, I mean I,
I have parts of my equity talk about
like a conspiracy theory in that type of
thing and I'm not into that.
But I'm always conscious,
like one of the words I avoid when
I do my act, this is the word we,
whenever somebody uses that,
it's a fucking turn off to me and
I feel like I'm being preached at,
I'm not really, ah, I learned weird.
I thought I learned writing word. No,
I know with the PR, depends
on how you do it, but I just,
I saw comic a long time ago at the comic
strip and I just remember he was going,
he was going on, on ongoing like,
you know, but do we do this now?
We want to country in that form yet.
Like you don't fucking
speak. That's silliness. Say,
say what you think about it and
then I'll listen to your opinion.
If I agree with it, I'll laugh.
Or you if I don't, if it's funny,
I'm going to laugh, but like,
uh, like I don't like being,
I don't like preachiness out like
being selfish fake shit. Yeah.
That you're being dangerous or yeah. Or
like pushing an image. Like, you know,
you're going on stage with an image.
You're trying hard to push it. Yeah.
I worked with this chick Laura House once.
She knows she is not a comic.
Funny girl from,
I believe she's from Texas and you
lived in San Francisco and uh, she,
when she met me, the first thing she
said, she took a deep breath. She goes,
I heard you're really like edgy and dark
and I was so worried that you're going
to show up wearing black. That's
hilarious. Areas she gives us worried.
You're going to be one of those cards
with a black shirt and black jeans sitting
in the green room and [inaudible] I
have a bill Hicks shirt that says,
do you think I'm wearing all black in
the summer because I'm a ray of sunshine.
It's like, you know, like I'm wearing
but I'm wearing black. I'm dangerous.
It is sort of fucking stupid.
It's an outfit.
No different than ones that someone
wears at Burger King or at a fucking
monastery. We're in a big stupid
orange row. I will give it a shot.
Him is his Leno bit was great,
like, yeah. And he had great shit,
but I shouldn't say some of us, some
of his stuff was funny. You know,
I laughed at it. But Ari, you know,
was like he was making a very,
very valid point that there's a
lot of like fluff in his business.
Just him talking about ideas.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I think it's interesting and you,
I don't need to laugh every minute to
be entertaining. It's like 20 later.
And then you're also
talking about a guy who went down a road
where you're not going to get a sitcom,
you're not going to leap to movies.
So there's,
you gotta give the Guy Credit that he
did that he had a lot of the statistical
integrity,
but that's also who he was. I mean, he
would just snug it was going to get one.
Anyway,
dude,
you're going to get tweets where people
are going to our emails where people say
Kinison socks. So it's, so it's one of
those deals where it all comes down to,
I definitely like personally for me,
the guy during that period,
for me,
what was,
but I have to be honest
with one time I watched, um,
I saw Richard Pryor's
first specials when I was,
but I hadn't even done comedy yet. I had
just moved out of my parents' house and,
uh, I was with my buddies
and we watched two, uh,
we had a VHR player in the
fucking VHS rather in a,
an apartment shitty apartment wall fam.
And uh,
we watched Sam Kinison and then right
afterwards we worked Richard Pryor and I
was like, wow, prior is way
better prior, first prior.
The first prior special is just
fucking brilliant. It was brilliant.
It wasn't that he was better, it's
just, I've almost felt like, God,
why was Kenton screaming so much?
You know what I mean? Like prior,
like Pri was so smooth
and so real on stage.
We're sitting as Kinison was putting on
a show, it was a brilliant fucking show,
but the way he was talking to you was
not the way you would really talk to
someone, you know? Oh, I was
mad for two fucking, yeah.
Whereas prior would be talking
to you the way you really felt.
You were drawn into him as a human being.
That's how I looked at.
There's certain is a very few guys,
but certain guys who just take it so far,
you can't be surpassed.
I would say him, James Brown,
all this music that has come,
no one has ever done it better than
that guy. You can't. You can't.
There's very few guys as a handful of
artists that they're just, you can't pass.
Have you ever seen the James Brown
live and Zaire clip you want to show?
We played this on here
once with Joey Diaz.
Find that Brion pull that shit up on
your iPad. James Brown live in Zaire. I,
I've seen that yet.
One of the greatest performances
the human race has ever,
the thing that was just one night. Yeah.
Yeah. Just one lady and I was like 50,
and he kept banging that
out all over the country.
He would throw that mic stand offish
shoulder and kick it and he just fucking
never missed a beat,
never slipped.
He had leather fucking slippery bottom
shoes on, spinning around. I also
liked as far as like,
you know when you work with the comedian
and after like two shows, you realize,
oh, this guy is going to do the exact
same jokes in the exact same order.
That whole shit we'll with a band,
he just starts.
If he decides he's just going to talk,
they just start playing on like a loop.
Like that's what I like when I,
when I watched like bands like
you can tell when they're,
when they're improvin is because they
don't look at the crowd there fucking
looking at the s there's waiting for some
sort of cue. Like what is it that one,
like Steve, when I used to watch
Stevie Ray Vaughan, like, uh,
like some of the live shit that
he did always knows Tommy Shanna,
Chris late in the drum and
the bass player in the drama.
They would always be
kind of looking in the,
and once you got educated to watching
him enough you would see the nods where
like sometimes they would be
looking, thinking out, here he comes,
he's coming out of an anti,
he's going back into more soloing and
then he'd be on his way out and he just,
we just sort of glance over at him and
then seamlessly that that shut shit just
blows me away.
People were able to do that.
It's just the practice together
all the time like that.
I guess you just get tuned in.
I don't know. I just, I'm not a
musician so I don't understand that.
You play drums, right? Yeah.
And that's the kind of thing,
but I'm like the same way I watch sports.
Like I'm a geek.
Like I wish I played in the NFL, but you
know, I wish she played drums. I wish,
no know I can play drums
at decent for a comedian,
but like the like how good
those guys are, man. Sure.
Like I went to a foul on tape
and I was watching the roots.
I actually got to see them
play during a break. Dude,
they're fucking ridiculous
raising. Yeah, ridiculous.
And they don't even have to look at
each other to us. What blows me away,
they just sort, Kj. Glen said,
man, let's do this for a while.
We think you're doing that when you,
when you go on stage and you're free
ball and sometimes talking to somebody in
the crowd and all of a
sudden it becomes a bit,
I mean how many times you've done that?
Someone will say something in the crowd
and you go, look at this fucking guy. He
thinks all the sudden he's at a carnival.
Hey, I'll have some
popcorn, please. You know,
and then you turn it into a fucking bit.
How many times have you done that?
And I've talked to people that
say after you get off stage,
like is that guy a plant? And you go, Nah,
I was just fucking around with that guy
though. You made all that up on the spot.
I don't want to think about it.
Is, is your locked into you right?
You got to fucking worry about the guy in
the bongos and the dude over here like,
is this guy paying attention
when I go to do this? Did he,
did he see what he just did like gave
the little nod like I don't get how it
works, but like maybe it's because I
can't do it then I'm so blown away by,
no, you're good point. I mean I can't
do it either. I mean I don't even,
I wouldn't even know where to start.
I think it's the same thing though.
I think when you tune into comedy,
I guess it's got to be harder because you
got to have a bunch of people that are
tuned into May. It's got to be all
about everyone making the song better.
It can't be all about like,
okay,
here's it's Tom for time for Tommy's
fucking drum solo. He needs a drum solo.
Every song or he gets pissed off and this
guy gets to go off and then it becomes
like self indulgent,
but there's,
when it's tuned in and it's just to
to make the song better and they do it
together, you know? I guess
that's what you like. Jazz
is supposed to be all about,
right? Everybody like does it
together to make the song better
me,
once I got out of that bad at that bed,
I can't let somebody sounds like five
guys playing five different songs on that
shit.
On my message board about this.
Cause I said that I hate jazz and uh,
I don't really hate jazz.
I just don't like it. I,
I shouldn't say I hated because I do
listen to it sometimes in the background.
Have you ever listened to that? Yeah,
I've listened to a lot of different shit.
I look, I don't, I, but I wouldn't choose
it over fucking the almond brothers.
You know, you choose it over. See
if it's fucking Leonard Skinner.
Alabama is the only thing I cannot fucking
listen to other than if it's early on.
Ban Dwight Yoakam I can listen to Dwight
Yoakam and that guy's a bad mother
fucker. And I even like some stupid shit.
I'll ask them to Coby Tz I like some of,
should have been a cow boy. I liked
that stuff. I know it's stupid.
I like stupid shit. I don't mind.
I like a lot of stupid shit.
It doesn't bother me that it's stupid. I
enjoy some of that, but often it's corny.
Me,
I just,
I get like douche chips when I listened.
I have a problem with people that
don't like Willie Nelson or something.
I shouldn't do this.
I shouldn't judge people.
But when some people don't like
certain things, I think badly of them.
Like this girl the other day said that
she didn't like now cause I don't like
those are,
those are fine things.
But this girl said she didn't like
Stevie Ray Vaughn. She's like, oh,
I can't listen to that. I go, what
are you talking about? She goes,
I can't listen to that. It's,
it's guitar stuff. It's terrible.
And I don't know her very well. So I just
walked someone who works for the UFC,
I just walked away. I'm like, okay,
well but all I think it was that Bro,
she's broken.
You don't like see you can't,
you don't like couldn't stand the
weather. Du Du, Du, Du, Du du Du
and it just because I've heard it
so many times culturally is man,
you smoke a joint and listen to Stevie
Ray Vaughan live. Listen to that shit.
Stevie Ray Vaughan and double
trouble live. I would introduce it.
He has a fucking live version of Voodoo
child that will knock your Dick into the
dirt. He has the only version of Voodoo
child that's right up there with Hendrix.
Put head.
Find that friend that when you use,
when you talk about a guy just took it
to the end and you can't be passed. Yes,
I would say him.
Stevie is as close as you can to that,
but he was definitely a major
deciphal yes. Of of Hendricks.
Just to put that out there
cause everyone's gonna to
be writing and going like,
oh actually he stole a lot from
Hendrix. Well yeah, he certainly did,
but he also was a huge Hendrix
fan and like broadcast that thing,
you know what I mean? He like, it
was all in, in homage to Hendricks.
He never pretend your fans to watch.
Just to watch Stevie Ray
Vaughan play are not tight rope.
Our Live Austin city limits. Yeah, it's
just add to, it's fucking me thinking.
He was a tremendous motherfucker dude.
He was a tremendous motherfucker. I,
you know, I almost got a chance to drive
him. I drove Jeff Beck around once I,
when I was driving limos and Jeff Beck
and Stevie Ray Vaughan were on tour
together and I was going to
get to drive Steve Ray Vaughan.
I was all psyched about it, but Steve
Ray Vaughan was such a bad mother fucker.
You wouldn't take limos,
took a cab everywhere he goes,
the band would all get in their limos
and their vans and he would just get in a
cab by himself and smoke cigarettes.
Listen to how good this is.
Cracked the shit out.
Jeff Beck is unreal.
It's a slightly different version.
I mean it's not what Jimmy
Hendrix did is different.
He's got like a little twain going on.
It's funny. Is in the middle. He does it.
He does a solo on one of them and he
actually is playing the harmony of a
Hendrickson when he played with a
band of Gypsies. Crank that shit up.
Brian.
This is the only guy that comes close
to Hendrickson with the song. Yeah. No,
it's overall stomps him. Oh yeah.
He came up is he's the man. I mean,
he's a complete original,
but there are both heroin addicts.
That ain't a coincidence.
Now here at the,
Steve really kicked up the name is coke.
His heroin to Roddy heroin
makes you feel that groove.
I don't know what it is with
those singers. Love that.
Heroin musicians love that.
Heroin
is a great one.
[inaudible] it you ever see when he got
booed now you got booed. Stevie Ray
Vaughan. I hope they're all in hell now.
Bring this down. This
is great. Why did they,
why did the performance gives me
chills to, this is what happened.
He went over to the, uh, still not as
good as Hendrix. Pretty God damn good.
But I was good. Yeah. That the
Monterey jazz festival he played at,
so they pursued him off
for some stupid reason.
They book them at a jazz festival
and he plays blues. He plays loud.
I mean other than that, like
Stang swaying. I mean it's
not a lot of jazzy shit.
So everybody had been playing
acoustic up to that point,
I think it was in France, I don't know
what it was. Somewhere over in Europe.
So he goes out there unknown and he went
out there and starts playing and stuff
and it took about two, three songs in and
they started booing them. But what are,
and you could see it was
affecting him those really,
but when they would start playing
the song, dude, he total commitment.
It gives me chills every time I watch
it eat. That's all. One of his DVDs,
they finally showed it and uh,
but that was the time when David Bowie
was in the crown and David Bowie's
watched him go on,
this guy's a beast.
That's how he ended up
playing the solo on that song.
Let's do while he was bombing.
That's funny.
You can bond way better as a musician
though, then you can as a comic,
as a musician I have to do is
just do the song as a comic you,
this was pretty brutal because he was
playing by the time he got to the third
song or something like you can od,
you can audibly hear boos. Yeah.
But the thing is is it's,
as much as it's bugging him,
he still fucking is,
is just ripping on the G.
It's unbelievable. And He, and
he gets off stage. I remember,
I remember reading a thing where he said,
I'm a total Seaver Yvonne head.
He got off stage and just like Jesus, I
didn't think we were that bad. And uh,
then of course he got with David Bowie,
but we wanted them to go on tour and do
like these dance steps and he wouldn't
fucking do, it was like, I'm not doing,
it's like a comedian not selling out.
And he went back to Texas.
I'm going to go back with my trio.
We're going to try and make it that way.
So we've got huge credibility that way.
And then, then he blew up. And then a
couple of years later he went back to, uh,
the Monterey jazz festival. Of
course, they were giving them a call.
He wanted them to do dead stumps.
Yeah. It was probably step one.
The second his car, he was like, Texas.
Two steps on my fucking balls here.
We're going to have a choreographer.
We're going to work together. And before
I performance, which we'll take a shower,
they wanted him. Yeah, he was, he was
going to be on the let's dance tour. Uh,
you know, we had that whole pop, you
know, put on your red shoes at Hong Kong.
There was some sort of thing.
He was coming down the stairs and he had
to do like some little dance step with
everybody else. And Stevie
would just, yeah, I'm not
doing it. We just walked down.
And then finally it was just like, ah,
I can't do the [inaudible] replace me.
Steve [inaudible] fucking
tour with David Bowie. Wow.
And I heard he also used
to get mad laws gossip.
I know he's gonna get mad at
the, uh, David Bowie video.
Wait for,
let's dance.
Is David boy with with a pair of gloves
on starts playing the solo that Stevie
played. I heard Stevie saw
the video was like, no,
he shouldn't be out there
fucking pretending like he
played some shitty didn't
play. Wow. Like all stuff like that. Wow.
This is all shit that just old like
I've poured through the Internet.
Just reading all these. That makes sense.
It's like comics that you know, I mean,
how many comics do you know that
looked down upon that hired joke
writers? You know, we know a lot
of guys. There's a lot of guys,
especially when they hit a certain
level, they really did become like, uh,
like almost like a figurehead.
They almost become like a character
and then they have guys write for them.
It looks old school guys especially, well
they have a lot of writers, you know?
Yeah. I mean, I know a guy who has like
five fucking writers and he's a, you know,
national headliner and he has all these
guys who come up with his own jokes for
him because he's too busy with
movies and all sorts of other shit.
So, but that, that is the way to do it.
This is a bad idea tank.
At least that's not the way to do it.
But like as far as a business model,
so you act never slips down.
Like I look at that with
like what it does slip.
I look at it with them because I go,
I could never fucking do that.
And I watched like five years from now,
here's the problem, here's the problem,
Louie.
Okay,
does it absolutely the best because he
does a new hour every year and he does
his own hour. It's all his writing,
right? When you hire somebody else, man,
you might agree that something's funny.
You might agree that you know,
this idea is funny and you might
use it as a tool. You say, well,
I'm going to go on stage. I'm going to
plug this thing in and press this button.
It's going to get a big laugh.
It's going to work,
but it's not going to be
your thoughts being pretty
Jeff. That's what I thought to get
fast. If I can't get past that,
how can I stay in and if it kills and
you'd be like, do you want to be like,
oh yeah, keep it going. For Frank, frank
wrote that one. You know no districts
back to the comics that we know that.
Do you use writers that do use writers
but they do not have the same impact on
me as guys like Norton or guys like
Louie or guys who I know write their own
shit. The Guy, so I know that's, this is
their thoughts like Norton especially,
I got Norton's new CD sent me despicable.
I heard it's awesome.
Fucking whole areas. It's very
fun. Gordon's, oh by the way,
Norton is doing my podcast tonight.
We're doing it live at the smog castle.
By the time you hear this,
if you're on iTunes,
it's Tuesday the 23rd and 22nd
do you use during meetings?
It's so it's,
it's probably not going to be on Ustream.
And if you're listening on iTunes,
it already happened.
But it's tonight we're going to do
a at nine o'clock at the smog cast.
We're going to try these out.
We're gonna start doing live
ones in front of an audience.
I think it'd be fun if 50 people,
we put the tickets online,
it's sold out in two hours.
So did these,
they already have like
Mike's and everything. They
have it all set up and you,
he has it completely wired for a podcast
and then he just put in an SD card and
he records it and gives it to you and
you can upload it that night. But anyway,
Norton is, I'm Greens down there.
It was great. Yeah, I did his too.
And Norton is doing my
thing tonight and not,
so I've been listening to a CD over the
like last night on the way to the gym.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's so twisted and
crazy. He's so funny, man.
I saw him when I was in Austin.
I was there for uh, the, um,
the UFC and I had the Friday night off.
So a buddy of mine who lives in Austin,
we, I said, hey, you know Jim Norton's
sales, go see him, fucking killed it.
He was show funny dude.
He made me want to go home and write
and he made me do shorter sets.
He did like 50 minutes and I've been
doing this thing lately where I did like,
I was doing like an hour and a half,
sometimes two hours and I'd do like a
big question in the answer at the end.
But I always felt like,
and a lot of ways it kind of like took
away from the energy of like just one big
powerful performance. Yeah. A huge
believer that you don't go beyond,
I've done.
And it's like,
you know, you do an hour. That's perfect.
They get at you funny. They walk out,
they got that excitement.
Yeah. No, cause I, you know,
whore myself out selling DVDs afterwards.
If I do an hour and 10 an hour and 15,
they come out like, yeah,
they're like this. Especially
if you don't close strong.
Yeah, no. Even if you do
though, even if you do,
it's just a fucking exhausted and it's
just like 50 to an hour is you've given
them their money's worth and
you've the classic show business.
You left them wanting more,
but like you go beyond that to what?
I saw a guy one time,
he did two hours. Okay.
Right in an hour I looked at my watch.
I just instinct avails and how much
has he done? Oh right now look at me.
This is my first kind of, okay again.
Yeah your, this is your take on the world.
I get it.
Then I'll 15 hour and 20 to one hour
and 25 my fucking ass to start to fall
asleep.
I agree.
A hundred by an hour and 35 I came up
with a strategy for me and my girl to
leave cause it was like,
what's that in a theater and it was
really going to be noticeable if we got up
and left and so I ended up
being the bad guy. She got up,
made it look like she was going to the
bathroom and then I just grabbed both our
cooks. I go, excuse me. She was,
and I saw people like, oh my God,
I can't believe he was walking out on it.
Really.
It really is too much to sit there
and listen to [inaudible] though.
Depends though.
Cause I've seen some guys,
I've seen some hour and a half sets while
I was fucking real happy that the show
didn't end.
Like I saw Chappelle do an hour and a
half for the comedy store and I enjoyed
the fuck out of it.
I enjoyed the whole hour and a half.
But then again I'm a stand up comic.
I'm going to on a sewer of comedy.
I had the night off. I don't fucking
have to get up at seven in the morning.
I don't have, at the time
I didn't know a, you know,
a a normal job that I had to go to
and work all day. So it's like when,
especially Friday night late show,
dude,
that shows fucking 10 o'clock these
people been up since seven you know,
that's a long ass time.
They're tired.
Ship your barn in the crowd
and they're drunk. You know?
I think it actually, it decreases them
wanting to come and see you again. Yes.
I definitely like if you
go out there and just
can you just blast to for an hour,
that's Boston style to Boston style is
short and nobody in Boston ever did a
fucking two hour set. They would look at
you like, what are you fucking retarded?
What did we do 40 remember those fucking
Nick's comedy stop sets where the
fucking headliner would do 20 minutes.
Everybody would do 20 I'm,
it'd be five guys do in 20 minutes and
they would do the same 20 minutes for a
hundred years and it would be honed to
a Samurai sword, sharpness, Don Gavin,
his timing,
he could talk about anything and it
would be brilliant because he had talked
about it so long he knew the exact right
beats and how to pause Knoxy all those
guys. Don Gavin made me think
that I shouldn't have been
in comedy. Made me think,
how could I ever be as good as this guy?
I was an open miker watching him fucking
destroy one night it was stitches,
comedy club. Okay. And
it was the new stitches,
which wasn't as good as the old stitches.
It was nice because it was bigger and
it had a restaurant attached to it,
but there was like carpet in the floor,
the ceiling, it was a little too high.
I didn't absorb the, it didn't bounce
back. The laughter like the old stitches.
Stitches with dark anyway,
the fucking shows long dude.
It was like an a an open
mic night and you know,
1520 unfunny want to
be over and over again.
Go Up. And I was one of them.
And then at the end, Kevin Flynn,
who was part of the pool, I was part of
the problem for sure. And I was thinking,
wow, this is audiences
exhausted. At the end,
Kevin Flynn brings up Don Gavin any
fucking crushes and crushed to the point
where me and Chris Mcguire and a couple
other guys were sitting in the back
room, hands in our face, like
the fucking home alone kid going,
we should just quit comedy. We can't do
this and will never be able to do this.
I'm never going to be that good. We're
going, we need to stop right now. No,
that was a great thing.
I think about that shit.
Like thank God I started there as fuck.
It was a few place like San Francisco,
Boston and New York is a great place
back in the day. Like now, not the same.
Unfortunately. The last stops gone and
now they just have, they do it on Sundays.
They call it the comics union I think.
But uh, the, the old laugh stop,
the old one in river oaks was
the shit, you know, that was a,
that was the place where, you know, I mean
Kinison started out back then, you know,
they used to have, it was the comedy
annex, I think they call it. They,
by the time I got out there, that place
was already gone. Unfortunately. Man, I,
I recorded my first CD there.
Yeah. And Hicks did his uh,
his first special sane man. Yeah,
yeah. At the same club that see that,
that that's that thing on the wall.
That's from [inaudible] 99.
That's what I recorded my,
those are my Warner brothers CD.
I'm going to be dead some day
and I did that in Houston.
That was when I was on
news radio on those,
there was only one place in the country
where I would sell out every show and
that was Houston. I'd sell out
way in advance. Like, like,
like I would sell out the whole
weekend by Friday. No, my dad says no,
I didn't do that anywhere else, you
know, and does nowhere else. But the um,
maybe I didn't, maybe I sold out like
one day in advance. What a point is.
There was no place where I would like
they would stuff in extra people in like
violate the fire code. Like when I
recorded my CD there, they stuffed in 50,
60 people over the fire code.
I mean, there was people,
there was chairs in the aisles and shed.
It was ridiculous,
but it was because that was the
style of comedy that they love.
Like Hicks and Kinison and they were
both dead by that time. They had grown,
like Houston had developed this table.
One of those guys left. Yes. Both of them.
I saw both of them live. I saw Kennison
live only as an audience member,
but as I Hicks alive when
I was already a comic,
I saw him live at least three times.
One time I left the room
because he wasn't doing so well.
So it was just like the
audience had no idea who he was.
And he was just onstage talking about,
uh,
Debbie Gibson and Jimmy Hendrickson was
just fucking, people weren't buying it.
You know,
there's a couple of times where I saw
him where he absolutely destroyed though
one time at the old comedy connection man,
where he was just on his fucking game.
Man, he just destroyed, just,
just came in there, guns blazing,
all this shit about Jim Fixx dying while
jogging and all that shit. You know,
because Jim Fixx was the jogging guy
and the Yule Brenner bit, you know,
he had a Yule Brenner,
Yule Brenner, you know,
Jim Fixx would get up and Dewey
track at dawn jogging and you'll run.
It would be coming home,
its head out of the limousine to chicks
blowing them smoking a cigarette and
they're both dead and he's like,
you know, he's dead. I'm dead.
Shit. That could be, I
was fucking up at dawn
doing. Yeah, I mean it was a really
lovely guys saw from back then.
I saw dice clay at the, at the height
of, I saw him at the Worcester Centrum.
I sat at the second to
last row in the upper deck.
Eddie Griffin or unknown Eddie Griffin
opened up and we were all like Boone ago
[inaudible] dice man. And I was doing
that. I was doing that dumb audience,
you know,
[inaudible] going to like us because
we're treating his opener like shit.
And Eddie Griffin was hilarious.
He's like, fuck you motherfuckers.
And then he actually got the crowd, he
turned him around and everything. But uh,
how old was I at the time?
28 I saw Tennyson when I was 19 when
I was working for a great woods.
I was wearing you for a
great woods performance arts
center and he's like, yeah,
I saw Eddie Murphy on the
raw tour. Oh, did you? Yeah.
I just didn't see Eddie Murphy out there,
but I saw bill Cosby.
I saw Rodney Dangerfield out.
Dangerfield out there to Dangerfield was
naked with a robe on who would go with
a bathrobe on and slippers
and that's how he'd do comedy.
Fucking naked as balls hanging out. He'd
go backstage as balls were hanging out.
He didn't give a fuck.
You like to do comedy naked with
a robot and destroyed. By the way,
one of the most underrated comics
of all time fucking destroyed.
He had the classic get
up with the red tag.
We see something that you said before that
I wanted to go back to because I both,
we both agree with this about this,
and I've talked about this before,
is that Hicks or not in a Hicks? Whether
the Kinison was genius in the beginning,
but then terrible at the end.
He's might be an example of a guy that
got famous and he got huge and then he
bought into his own hype and
then he became a character.
He stopped writing when he was at doing.
I don't think I've ever
seen a guy handled it worse.
If you just watch the difference
between his first and second Letterman,
his first Letterman, like, you
know, they say that like, you know,
they give that intro like,
Jesus, we don't this next guy,
the next guy's going to be different.
We know does that air of like
something crazy could fucking happen.
And usually it's just hype will, this
guy's crazy. But it's, it's, his act is,
he's crazy, but it's like Kennison
it was real. And he came out, dude.
I mean he just fucking came out and he
was walking up into the crowd and it
wasn't cheesy, it was just, it was, it
was amazing. And then the second one,
he comes in, he just comes, you
know, do you know that his face,
what's going on day? And he just
was just like relaxed to him. Yeah,
he was just like a, I made it not hungry
yet. I made it. He's a fat guy, you know,
at the end of the day he's lazy.
I mean that's really true.
I mean fat people are fucking lazy.
You know his personality in his book,
his brother Bill, his
brother, his brother's name,
I forget his name, I met him,
unfortunately, I forgot his name.
Whatever his name is. I'm sorry,
whoever you are as Rocco,
his brother who wrote the book wrote
that he was a normal kid and then you get
hit by a fucking truck. He got hit by
a car and when you get hit by a car,
he got fucked up and he came
out of that head injury,
a completely different person.
And then it became like reckless and
fearless and all fucking wild person like
the accident literally made him Sam
Kinison. I mean, cause you think about it,
I'm like, who the fuck
thinks like that? Who
has that kind of boldness to go on
stage and scream and yell about things?
You know? And did you ever
see when he was preaching,
you ever see the videos of him
preaching? Yeah. Hey man, it's great.
Holy Shit.
I mean it was so,
there was like a rhythm to someone
preaching when they believe have a Lord
touches me. You're like, fuck. I mean,
knowing what I know what I'm saying
is nonsense. The applause break. Yeah.
And nobody knows how to build.
They fucking like you're,
that's why he was such a good comic.
Cause you would add those principles.
He would draw it out.
Like ladies and gentlemen,
I know the devil's in this room. And they
were like, oh, we'll bring them down.
Yeah,
the devil would like you to believe that
there's something wrong with the Lord.
You know?
And then he starts walking back and
forth and then it builds up to this.
But I'm here to tell you,
James, that says a lot, Jay,
this is where he's with.
And then everybody's fucking screaming,
dude, I gotta tell you she would do. I
don't buy any of the, any of that shit.
But I love watching preachers. I
watched the guy that, you know,
we just clearly a bigoted psychopath,
but he was fucking a phenomenal
performer and you know that guy,
he would, he would bring up
people who like, uh, you know,
who were living like probably
the life that we're living in.
And he had this way of saying what they
were doing and then he would just sort
of look to the side and shake and you'd
get a laugh every time I got now he
would read a quote with
somebody said like, you know,
this guy says premarital
sex is not a bad thing.
It doesn't want to think for yourself.
It doesn't do anything bad to your soul.
Right.
And then he just had this look,
he was like Carson watching Carson
when he would look over at the band.
He just had this thing where he would
just sort of looked down and the crowd was
just like, oh, here he comes. He's
going to take the piss out of this guy.
You know what I mean? It's like watching
your favorite wrestler. Like here you go,
here we go. Then the guy builds it all
the way up and I would just, you know,
and it was one of those things where he,
I would actually start getting into it
like, hey, maybe this guy's got a point,
and then they would just say something
horrific about gay people or just
something that just, you
just, you're like, God,
this is how does an adult
think something like me,
while he probably couldn't wait to
get off stage and fuck some kid,
I ain't go to Thailand, Bang
some kids. Yeah. You know,
do what I got in this huge thing with
this fucking guy in the internet.
Like it's the last time
I'm getting with like,
I fucking like 10 deep
on emails and emails,
deep diameter and about what?
About how I said why I stopped going to
Catholic Church and this guy was upset
at that. Yeah. And he knew, bothered to
argue with that because I'm an Ada yet,
like I come from a, you know, I can't,
I take the fucking budget, use that one.
Um, guilty because note,
because there's, there's a, uh,
a sense of, uh, I don't
know what the fuck it is,
what the word is that super
religious people have that, you know,
you just wanna boners no,
you just want to expose
like their bullshit. Right.
All right. So I just said,
listen,
you know,
I stopped going because I was going to
church and every time the basket came
around and I was putting the money in,
I felt like I was giving money for a
fucking defense attorney did offend these
guys who look the other during
pedophilia, right? Or whatever.
So He's,
his big issue was saying that I couldn't
say that they were kid fuckers because
most of the people who got violated
were teens. And I was like, oh,
great. See you grade on a fucking scale.
So he directs me to this Wikipedia page.
It was over 10,000 fucking incidences
that they're talking about it.
This is just the ones that were reported,
forget about the kids who killed
themselves and didn't come forward because
they're too embarrassed.
They 10,000 instances,
22% of them were 10 10 years
of age and under. So I go,
let's just round it off to 10 grand.
That's 2100 cases of dental and a kid.
How many kids do you gotta fuck before
you get labeled as a kid? Fuck her.
Because the other ones and a and he was
trying to spin it that I was actually
helping pedophiles because I wasn't going
to church and the church did all these
things and people back in the
day were confused. They thought
was it? You got trolled thought it was
like a spirit. Second thing I was me,
you got trolled by a 14 year
old pretending to be religion.
No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. Cause it happened possible.
Possible. You can't trick me. I know.
A real really know but
no, cause there's, there's certain,
there's certain things that he was going
through cause I was sitting at some
point goes this guy just
trying to piss me off,
but two he got all the way into the
fucking, I'm a correctional officer.
My grandfather was a correctional officer
and I work with these pieces of shit I
made. If I did, it was the greatest
one ever. [inaudible] website.
Yeah. Everyone's in their trolls. Seems
easy. It seems like I want to try it.
I know. I'm thinking about
getting a vague email gets low.
I fuck with you every day.
I'm going to bring up [inaudible] like
there's people who go to those churches
who aren't that fucking
stupid would there is,
but there's a lot more people that would
like to fuck with you now that they
know how easy it is. Look,
my message board right now,
they're sharpening up their
dicks right now. Right dress,
but it's over. No, no, no,
no. Not Him. You say it's not, they're
going to get nice and subtle with you.
They're going to start off nice and slow.
They're going to say something to you
about some picture of the timeline of you
grow your Dayton. Yeah. Just don't send
any photos of you and your Dick. Yeah.
At the same time that your face and
you're going to know some shit about you
that's personal, some inside
shit and they're going to
exploit it. Your fuck? Nah,
Nah. You've got an issue,
bro. You're you're, you're
in trouble. I'm not theories.
Easy to troll.
I'm not in screen capturing things.
You were thinking about coming to Jujitsu.
I talked to you about it for awhile.
You were thinking about doing it.
Just even if you don't want to do that,
get out God damn punching bag.
It'll make a better bill burr.
Just get a bag of gloves. It's so easy.
That's nice and cute and shit, but
you get off telling me that I
need that to not take the bait.
You Joe are really worse at this than me.
I'm telling you this is what happened.
You basically just said that I got trolled
and I used your presenting it as fact
having not read any wild,
obviously additional
candidates. You're arguing core.
Who are you with? Me? [inaudible]
you fucking listeners.
[inaudible] sending me fucking
emails. It's ridiculous. Easy.
This is how easy it is to get you
upset you or trolled right now.
Tell you right now,
I
could get you. I could get you if I didn't
tell you what my feelings about weed,
where I couldn't. I had you standing
up with a fucking vain, even high.
I could make you freak out if I,
if I pushed your buttons,
I was still laughing at you. I would
say it's ridiculous. Oh, that's right.
I forgot this is, this is the
new spot. Joe Rogan. Come on out.
Jesus. Stop his joke. Joke. Joke me. Well,
one of the great things about being a
psycho as you can spot another one across
the room for you to sit here, but I
managed my psychosis better than you.
That's all it is, buddy. I'm all Tom
saying you've got, you've not signed them.
I have it on the line. A bubbling
brook in the back. I get it.
Not Saying I got it under the
one that I'll go with that,
but you're a little out of hand.
You're going
back and forth with a guy who believes
that the church protects pedophiles.
Yeah.
I like to debate.
I go back and forth with fucking
jets fans. I hate the phone Jack.
I go back and forth on them.
Did you hear about this fucking guy?
You know, I'm only kidding, right?
What about all, I mean, I don't really
think you're a loser. I don't think that.
Now you never said,
I'm going to interrupt. Think that
you're going to be easy to troll. I know.
I want people to know
that this all in fun.
I want people to know that this is all in
fun people. Right moment on the pocket.
People
don't understand. Like people go, Whoa,
fucking these idiots on my message board.
We go Joe Rogan to Bill Berg on issues.
I thought,
but they really got into it all.
You hear bill first, Joe Comics,
fuck around like this all the time.
This is what we do.
And especially people that, uh, you know,
especially if you live on the west coast,
she never really understand
that sort of sense of humor.
It's why people didn't
understand that Gilbert Godfried
thing. To me, it was like,
you know, when, when he started
tweeting about Japan, I'm like,
east coast comic would
do, I mean, you know,
you gotta you all want to go for the
juggler. Yeah, I didn't like to do,
but how he leave in new,
he did the voice of the duck.
You know who fucking
just like that classic.
Certainly it's a lot of Japanese people
that were in this insurance competence.
One of the reasons why I was a busy
always. Now did you hear about this?
A high profile Vegas drug
prosecutor. This guy, uh,
he busted Bruno Mars. He busted Paris
Hilton on all, on cocaine charges.
He got arrested for buying crack head.
You gotta believe that she must
know who you hang out with.
But I was thinking about this when
we were talking about, you know,
the pedophiles and you know,
all these fucking crazy people that
don't want to believe. It's like w how,
how many people that go against
something really want to do it.
I mean, how many fucking people like that?
How many people that are against gain,
like the Ted haggards of the world that
are against gay marriage against gay,
this, against that, let's say
something like that. Yeah, yeah.
I remember that guy that got busted
in New York. You're really recently,
he was a a judge or something like that.
He got busted and some sort
of an influence scandal and
it turns out that he was
a voting against gay marriage and
he was fucking gang, you know,
the guy's gay and he was living
with a guy and he's, you know,
making all these votes against gay
rights. Yeah. Which goes back to religion.
They just let people live and
be who the fuck they were.
Then you wouldn't have
people doing shit like that.
But as far as like the drug thing I think
is a lot of people don't have to drugs
that they, they seriously are. I like
against him. But, uh, I
think you know the thing,
you've got to watch out who you hang
out with because you end up doing what
they're doing.
I think eventually you just try it.
You think you're in the evidence room.
Wow. Really. You fill tried crack,
you're feeling a little sleepy.
You can leave me alone with buckets of
crack in my house and I'm not going to
smoke it. Yeah, but can you just
leave it all over the place?
I'm never going to touch the crack.
This is what I would do.
I leave you with booze first,
get you when you're like 11 you know,
and we moved away. This is
a developed human, which is
like a gateway drug, right?
You go to the weed,
then that must've then it all depends
on what you want to feel like for you.
I see why the way your makeup,
you want to feel less smell like
Joe Rogan on coke. You'd start,
you'd be like Godzilla. He'd start
stepping on fucking skyscrapers downtown,
so it would be hard to get
you to go the crack route,
but like hallucinogenics and that type
of thing. It'd be, well my buddy Jimmy,
when I was in high school and my buddy
Jimmy used to do coke and he told me,
whatever you do, don't do it. You'd like
it. Don't do it. Yeah. That's my resume.
Well,
that's why I never really fucked her
another week because I knew when I finally
did it, I loved it. I definitely
loved it and I, that's,
I get a lot of shit in my podcasts cause
people think I'm anti wait cause they
fucking more, I got a million
tweets around those. Yeah,
no it's, I'm not anti weed.
I'm just saying stop acting like it's
not addicting like this that it's just,
it's just like alcohol. Well No,
it's not just like alcohol, but in,
that'd be addictive.
Psychologically.
Physically though physiologically is not
physically whatever, psychologically,
what do you want to call it? But like
those wake and bake guys, those guys,
I got a buddy of mine who smokes
weed because I said, why do you,
why do you like doing in a seriously
fucking with his life and he's going to do
weed is not the issue. And I go, why?
First of all, why do you do it? He goes,
I like weed because it
turns my life into a movie.
All right. And it's like this
dude, like, I don't know.
I don't want to fucking rat
them out or nothing like that.
But he's lost the job because
he flunked a fucking drug test.
That's a shitty job. And every job
that was their job sucked. Okay.
Any job that you can do that's
boring as fuck you can do on weed.
And it becomes interesting. You know? I
find, I'm not saying that it's a bedroom,
I'm saying,
but this guy,
he gets fucking high because
he's just keeping life.
Yeah. He's using it the way an Alka
uses alcohol, where it's just like,
I got all this pain. I don't how to
process it. I don't want to deal with it.
Let me just, let me just get fucked
up. That's how he does it. And Dude,
I'm telling, and the thing about it,
think about it is too, with weed,
is I can't go to work drunk. You know
what I mean? But you will be high,
you can go to work fucking high, and as
long as you're going to handle your shit,
people aren't gonna fucking notice.
I just,
there's a bunch of emails I gotta gotta
gotta go, you know? Yeah, I handle,
we straight just every night I smoke a
little fucking bowl and then I go to bed
and it's just like, well what if I, you
know, drank a beer and a half, two beers.
So I got buzzed every fucking night.
People will be looking at me like, dude,
I think, I think you have like a
drinking problem that you have to get.
He's like sedating himself. So he's
using it as like a fucking sleep aid.
I'm not saying that,
but I don't have any problem with me.
I think it makes you feel
great and that type of shit.
It's just like anything as long in
moderation. But people who sit there like,
and annoys me that on intervention,
they've never had just some pothead
who's been fucking high since he's 16 and
he's still watching like fucking the
Hanna Barbera hour. And you know,
cause it doesn't compare to the math
guys pulling his face off with his
fingernails. And I know that she
seems a lot worse. That's the,
don't know that that's definitely worse.
But that's,
that's what then if you know meth heads,
they're the fucking worst.
Does that mean you shouldn't go after?
It was all the difference
between not being
in your normal state. You know,
you're escaping your normal self.
So even if your wheat stoned
all day, you're escaping,
you're, you're sober self,
your, your core self, which
is always a problem in some
ways. You know what I mean?
Like just people,
I drive better when I'm high and I know
exactly the way he's talking about.
There's so many people that we know
that just wake up from the beginning.
They wake up, they have to get stone
to the go to bed and they're never,
they're sober self because
they're hiding something.
You know, they all have in common
photo bombing. I agree. I agree.
100% of the vaporizer,
it's probably a thousand
times more healthier than
drinking a fucking six pack.
You know what they all have in common?
They're all fucking hilarious. Yeah,
absolutely. Listen, when I was on
fear factor, I totally self medicated.
I used to get high before every show.
After the first season,
I got high before every fucking show.
I was so bored doing that show.
I mean, sometimes it was cool. Don't get
me wrong, I'm very happy I had the job.
It was a fucking wonderful opportunity,
great people to work with the
producers and everyone was the fucking,
the crew grow fantastic.
It was just a wonderful job.
But I would rather be doing
other shit, you know? Yeah.
I wanted the money and I wanted to do
it and I wasn't gonna quit. But Mandy,
you know, at certain
points in time, I mean,
how many fucking animal Dick's
can you feed people? But we like,
what the fuck am I doing with my life?
You know,
how many times can you hang somebody by a
crane and go, ready? Three, two, one, go.
Right.
You know how many is to think about you.
It's like you smoking weed doesn't
affect you from prevent you from fucking
coming up with the new hour of material
doesn't prevent you. It doesn't, it helps.
I ended. Okay. Yeah.
And you're not slacking off and just
watch some cartoons fucking up your
motivation. All right. So, yeah,
I'm not saying like people just thought
I was just straight across the board
saying it was bad.
I wasn't saying that.
I was just saying like I just got sick of
people going, yeah, it's not addicting.
I drive better when I'm high and like,
like there was no repercussions.
Like there's repercussions to
fucking everything. You don't,
especially if you're smoking that Fuckin
Oji Kush that a lot of dudes like to
smoke that that Endeca,
there's two different types of weeds,
sativa and Indica and the sativa is,
or like more heady,
like you want to go watch a documentary
on space and the indycars you just want
to watch cartoons and eat
cereal and sleep. You know,
they're two really different effects
and most of the country only gets that.
We'd most of the country gets the
sleepy weed. They get to college.
You know what I found lately that
sleepy weeds the best we'd have sex on.
That's like ecstasy on weed. Yeah,
they're kind of makes sense. Yeah. Well,
you know what though? The regular is
pretty awesome to the regular, you know,
what's the best for sex? Eating weed. When
you eat wheat, you get that body. You get
that because it's,
you know,
it really affects you in a different
way because it's a different chemical.
When you knew it's processed by your
liver and that's the best for second.
It's like everything feels better.
Watch the Oscars and it
was like the Best Oscars.
Why was I heard that there was some
bad monologue or something. I didn't,
I don't watch any of that nonsense.
I think people awards for ours.
It's ridiculous. Was the moment James
Franco, you could just see tapped.
I was just like, ah, fuck this. He got,
I came out in a dress and
you're not going to laugh at me.
Go Fuck yourself and just had this
look on his face and I keep working.
Who gives a fuck? It was great. He
says, take my phone out and check.
It was like a comedian when you
just look at a crown and they got,
these people are fucking idiots.
Well, how about the shitheads that
got upset at a, what's his name?
The English guy. There was, yeah,
there was doing the Golden Globes.
They got upset at him
cause he was shitting on everybody.
But I didn't think he deserved
any sort of edgy points.
I mean it's like you show
up and you, you, you,
you have a staff of writers write
roast jokes and you took his jeep like,
yeah cause been done heavy. That was
like, like it was this amazing fucking,
can you believe in,
know you fucking get a staff writers
to write roast jokes to sling them at
people armed with acceptance speeches.
It's like,
and then when you did go down and
fucking start slapping around some first
graders,
I just think that that's a gig where
it's really easy to come off as edgy.
I mean given were gasping
and what was he doing?
I'll Robert Downey JR Rehab joke.
It goes back to that Hicks Shit that
you were talking about. It's just like,
I thought it was really like, uh,
like I just look at that Gig boy,
that's like the comic where you get like
a corporate gig and they go, listen,
don't talk about this, don't talk
about this and we're clean. Okay.
And you agree to it.
And then you go out there and then
you just say fucking blah, blah blah,
and you're walking around like you're
fucking Lenny Bruce. You're now,
you just have to do,
if you didn't want to do the Gig,
if you don't like celebrities,
do you think they fucking suck?
What are you doing there? And awards
show with the fucking Tuxedo on.
Greg Fitzsimmons was telling me the
story about a Gig that he did in New
Hampshire,
you to drive up there,
it's like fucking four hours
in the middle of nowhere.
And he did the Gig and they told them
whatever you do, you can't swear.
Don't say fuck. So he
goes on stage, he goes,
apparently I'm not supposed to
say fuck like what's that about?
He gets off stage, they have his bags
packed like right there by the side says,
get the fuck out of here. You're fired.
And so he has to drive home and you know,
he was telling it to rich slicer actually
and slicers like Dan let you drive
home at night.
Usually they tell you to never drive
at night because there's a moose.
They're like, fuck this
kid. He said the evil word.
But yeah, that's a Douche. But that's
a thing you do when you're 20 you know,
you're like, yeah, that's how I
always viewed it. I viewed it like,
cause I went through that period,
but I sort of viewed it like,
it's like they're telling you what they
want and they hired me to do this and
you're agreeing to fight.
It's like that fucking kid at Byu.
Everybody's flipping out. Like he had
sex and they kicked him off the team.
They said what they expected and you
signed a fucking contract, you know,
don't go to this school.
Yeah.
But the idea of stopping teenagers
for fucking, it's just like saying,
I'll drink water is ridiculous. I'm not
saying it's smart, I don't agree with it.
I think it's fucking ridiculous.
But
who in their right fucking mind
signs a contract and says, I'm not,
I'm not gonna fuck.
Dan had to have been all written up back
in the fucking dark ages though, right?
It was in Brigham Young University.
That's a Mormon University. Right.
I don't agree with it, but it's one
of those things. Don't take the Gig.
You're telling me that guy couldn't put
a ball through a hoop and someplace else.
Yeah, but it's not like Byu is his fucking
North Carolina or some really like,
you know,
traditional like where they were all
these like Jordans and James Worthy's came
from. Byu is like the best they got. They,
they've had a couple of seasons with
like Steve Young and Jim Mcmahon.
They've had like great,
great teams with their football,
but now with basketball it's fucking Byu.
No idea what you're talking about.
Now you lost [inaudible]. Right? But
you know what your listeners see,
right? Do they, they know sort of sports
football for the losers out there.
All right. It would be like kidding.
I don't think you're losing.
If you like basketball, right?
Settle Down, put your panties,
straighten them out and say this is Sydney
thinks he's going to get on with that.
Talking about them, not you. I'm
talking about those people out there.
Then you just get upset because I said,
you're a fucking loser if you're
like basketball. And then I'm like,
relax everybody on Twitter. I'm just
joking around. These are just jokes.
These are just chokes.
And did you see Gallagher?
I heard that he fucking got
a stroke on stage right now.
I saw I was on the local news when
a satisfying things I've ever seen.
He's standing outside of his
house that he somehow owed.
He's owned for 30 years
and he's having an auction.
He's selling all it half the
shit you've seen in a special.
Why selling these off?
Because he's losing his house.
Jadon tells losing his house.
Yeah. I'm telling you right now,
there aren't fucking TV. Talk about Barry
Bonds and Roger Clemens and what they,
you know what baseball means?
They should be hunting down these bankers
and fucking shooting him between the
eyes.
Oh wait a minute.
The owner house for 30 years and
you're getting kicked out of it.
I thought it's a 30 year loan money.
Type it in the SEC is loan. So you know,
he really puts a second
mortgages and probably didn't
pay it. I didn't hear that.
He got,
he was getting kicked out of his house.
He was like selling large bananas and
he just had a fucking heart attack on
stage to it. I don't get how you're
in a fucking house for 30 years.
You're doing road gigs and you somehow
can't afford to keep your fucking house
to those mortgages. It's modern day
fucking slavery. It's ridiculous.
How can you say that when you say that
a kid should be able to go to Brigham
young and sign a contract that he's not
going to fuck. You don't think that.
It's just as ridiculous that someone
signs a contract for a second mortgage on
there. This is why they're green to that
because you can't live outside home.
Well, you're a fucking idiot. You're
an idiot, man. If you're homeless,
you better have some
friends sleep on the couch.
You're the dummy wants to take out a
second mortgage when you think you can pay
it off. I mean, it's an
agreement. It's like it's not,
you're not dealing with
a long a loan shark who,
I completely disagree reeling
because I felt like first of all,
it shouldn't take you 30 fucking years
to pay the thing off. Didn't take,
you'll get 30 years.
You shouldn't take a Donald Trump.
30 years is a lot of people
that play this capitalism game.
They figured out a way to
do it and this guy didn't,
he didn't pay his fucking bills. It's
that simple. Organic or something crazy
organic watermelons. Maybe something
happened. We don't know about.
Forget it right now. It's just
how the game is set up, dude.
Banks and insurance companies are the
two most crooked motherfuckers out. Yes,
I agree and as you get older you start
having health fucking problems and you
have a little heart attack
and then you got it.
You know you get hospital bills through,
right? They look, this is what the deal.
They want you to run on the wheel for 30
years and then they want you to fuck up
financial to, they can kick you
out and stick somebody else.
Listen to what you're saying.
You are right now doing exactly what
you say you hate comedians doing.
They want you to do this and
they want you to do that.
That's just the same as we this
the same thing. Notice you're,
you're making this them,
which you're doing is you're being like,
the guy sent me the email and you're
defending pedophiles in a financial way.
I'm not defending them at all.
You're saying,
I think the system is completely fucked
up and did a lot more people should be
in jail. They, Bernie Madoff. They should
fucking front end load the interest.
I think Gallagher made millions
of dollars. That's what I think.
And I think of Gallagher lost his house.
He's probably a fucking idiot.
Absolutely.
And then I heard Gallagher on the Marin
podcasts like running off and I've seen
Gallagher on opie and Anthony.
He's a douchebag.
All those stupid jokes he was trying
to play on Patrice. This is that.
This is the thing,
this is what I can't stand about.
This shit is Gallagher's the douchebag.
But what about the fucking bankers do
that made homeless guys qualified to get a
fucking home? That's a
different argument. They drive.
They were talking about Gallagher.
I'm never getting back. It's Calico.
I'm never going to defend defend
Gallagher or bankers or Gallagher.
Fuck Gallagher. You know, obviously
I don't know the guy's finances shit.
It just got any chance I had to
take a shot at fucking bankers.
Have you seen inside job yet?
It's on the wall.
Just got it and I'm going
to watch it tonight.
I was going to watch it last night,
but I try to fix my pool stroke guy named
Stevie more told me my elbow comes up
in a funny way. I gotta fix my pool's
trucks. I've been telling you, doctor,
you have been watching pool instructional
[inaudible] Estrada than a fucking hot
chick who's good at pool.
There's a few,
but the problem is you don't
want to beating you. You
don't want to grow beating.
You know that's a very masculine game.
I know guys that were going on
when I would play in a tournament,
so they didn't have to play women. They
would freeze up. Even good pro players,
they freeze up. They panic because
I don't want to lose to a chick.
I think Bullard chicks he bench
pressing more than does matters.
She's playing pool into a whole who
is a very manly game cause it's about
controlling your instincts and controlling
your emotions and staying calm and
focused and showing that you
can fire under when you're,
when they're under pressure,
like pull like the most,
the big thing about pool is not playing
for fun. The big thing about pools,
gambling, that's where pool really
what? Pool meeting halls. A manly, well,
what pool means is pooled the money in
and gamble. That's what it was invented.
I mean that's literally the name, the
origins of the name pool, the game,
his pocket billiards.
That's the real game.
It's called pool because you
fucking gamble on it. And when,
when guys are gambling,
man,
last thing we'll do is lose money to a
chick and a game. When you dog the ball,
you panic and you think, oh don't
miss this nine ball. This is yet.
This is everything.
Put the jars in the moment when
he's going to lose to her in the,
in the driving thing. Yeah,
man. Gotta beat Marsha.
Got To get closer than a quarter of an
inch and he knocks the fucking egg off
the coast in man.
I remember I had a sit up contest with
my cousin when I was like 11 and I was
fucking so devastated that she was
beating me in this sit up contest.
I was super upset or 11. I know,
but look, some people don't mature.
Some guys, it just, look,
I've lost the girls and tournament's
before and I didn't enjoy it back when I
was like in my early twenties.
I didn't like it at all
playing some fucking a woman.
Anything other than an argument.
If I lost an argument that would fucking
kill me. I really just, I mean, just like,
like whatever. She yelled louder
than me. I mean, like she got down,
she just got just like reams of
information and that's why you're wrong.
Go Fuck Yourself. Has that ever
happened? That would drive me nuts.
Has that ever happened? I lost an arm
to the uh, yeah, but this is the thing.
Um, I, I don't, I should have
clarified that not a girl
I'm in a relationship with.
Right. That's a big thing
with me. If I'm wrong,
I admit I'm wrong in a relationship.
You got to do that because then
you're setting up if they're wrong,
for them to tap up and that,
that will save and do,
you just had a little help a lot and
you know, you're right. You're right.
I flipped up. I shouldn't have yelled at
that guy. You're right. Blah, blah, blah.
What it,
it shows,
it shows like a willingness to grow
and honesty and things that people
appreciate. I appreciate that
in friendships too. When a,
a friend will come up to me,
dude, I, I shouldn't have
said that to you. I'm sorry.
I appreciate that.
That's what about strangers?
You don't give a shit and you get no,
fuck. You fuck you back with them.
If they actually, if they actually, uh,
like I had a victory in and turned it
into a loss about fucking about a month
ago I was sitting in my car and I'm happy
doing this phoner this meeting, right?
And I'm outside the bank, right? And
this girl pulls up, gets out of a car,
opens the car door right into
my door, boom, hits it and like,
but didn't even react. I mean,
not like really hard, hard enough,
but it was the fact that she didn't
fucking react that I actually questioned.
I'm like, did she just maybe,
I dunno, is it that maybe I,
I thought she did it or whatever.
So I'm still on the phone doing
this conference call, right.
She fucking comes back out. She
does it again. So I'm on comp,
I get these people on speaker 10
noise. So I said, hang on a second.
I opened the door. I said, hey, I go,
you just opened your car door to my car
on the way into the bank and on the way
out of the bank. And she goes,
oh, I didn't chip the paint. I go,
chip. The paint. He didn't even look,
why don't you be a little
more considerate next time?
And I slammed the door so I won game set,
fucking match. And then like an idiot,
I still have to look over at
her and she just goes, smile,
have a nice day.
Like I'm an asshole for getting upset.
And then she gave me the finger
and drove away. She kind of,
she kind of stole around on me.
It's like I won and I got when
sugar ray Leonard that yeah. Yeah.
Like when you hang on one that fucking
fight by the way you like to the little
fucking American flag shorts
decided my head and I was like, oh,
why did I look at her?
I should just spend like be a little more
considerate. I had the slam of
the door at everything you do.
You know the conspiracy on that fight is
that Hagler through it and then Hagler
a kudo knocked out Leonard, but he
was hitting him with pity pat punches,
which if you watch it,
it really doesn't look like the same
kind of punches he threw on with Gabi and
Hearns. It looks like
he was like, you know,
almost like three quarters speeding his
punches because I am genuinely looked
devastated when they lie,
when these problems is why I should,
should've never fought in Vegas.
Maybe. I mean, but he retired. Look,
it was close enough. I did. He could
have lost decision. He retired. I mean,
only if he doesn't see it that way it's
as ego because it was pretty close.
You can see a decisions are squirrely.
Anything could happen.
Judges don't have monitors. No, he didn't.
No one got knocked down that fight.
I thought he'd knocked him down.
I believe so. I don't think so.
I don't think Hagler ever
knocked down. Leonard, hold on.
You didn't knock him down.
Maybe I'm thinking one of his,
all the fines that was the worst
watching liner down knock guys down.
They really usually didn't get up to how
great was the Middle Weight Division.
But what I was saying is amazing,
but what I was saying is that, um,
he sent her, Nah, Nah, Nah, I don't
think he knocked him down. Um,
when we're saying is though
that he retired and he
moved to Italy and it became
a fucking movie star. Yeah. And it's like,
look, if the mom really wanted a bet,
a shitload of money on the,
the underdog,
which is sugar ray Leonard fighting
this destroyer, who is Marvin Hagler,
just fucking crushed.
Tommy Hearns was knocking everybody
senseless and sugar ray Leonard had fought
years and years, you know,
he's older. He would look like,
even when people didn't ever think
anybody ever came back and was successful
because most of the time they weren't.
I thought he did.
Is he looked like he did a
cycle before that, that fight.
He was, Leonard did. Yeah.
He was huge.
Didn't Tommy Hearns accused him of that?
Tommy Hearns accused him of that before
their second fight. Oh, Atlantic. Yeah.
Yeah. I do know he, when he,
when he won that fight in any,
he did the classic flex dude. He was
like, you know that guy, you know,
I don't know. You know who they're
going after is Lance Armstrong? Ooh.
They're going after him,
man Damn. And Barry bonds
forever. But they got a lot in.
They've got a lot of information then
there's, fuck no, no, they gotta stop.
We gotta Stop Martha Stewart.
We've got to say that. Yeah,
we got stop Rodger Clements. This is just,
it's just fodder. It's too, it's true.
You're totally right. It's a good
point. Yeah. It's kind of crazy.
It's not that it's, it's not that it's
baseball. It's what baseball represents.
While it's like what the fucking
bankers that's, does it represent it?
That is our of losing their houses a
lot worse than someone losing a fucking
baseball game. Let's just bothers me
every week that I work. And then I go,
it's just everybody works. And you go
and you just give these cuts your money.
You hand it over like a fucking
child, like a child. Well, here,
here's the very worst. What the
fuck does money even mean anymore?
It's not even backed up by anything.
That's just based on your confidence.
A piece of paper that used to be,
uh,
what you could claim gold that you
can now no longer claim that gold for.
The most maddening thing to me is these
people that used to work for the sec
used to be investigating
these big companies and then
when they retire they get
huge jobs inside these companies.
Like how the fuck is that legal?
How is that allowed?
How you let people profit off of the
fact that they build some sort of a
relationship with these big fucking
financial institutions that are raping the
public and taking
all this buyout money and paying off
their fucking executives giant bonuses
while they lost billions and they're
paying these guys 40 million,
30 million like what is going
on? How was this? It's like,
oh and robbery in front
of everyone's eyes.
I feel like they're in tight, but it
isn't because nobody liked. They just Bam,
Brittany Spears shaved her head.
Yeah, we're bombing Libya.
Folks were bombing Libya.
Do not pay attention to the hundred mile
long streak of oil that we just knew.
We discovered in the Gulf.
You hear that there's a new fucking
oil spill in the Gulf, a new one,
a giant 100 miles long. 20
miles from the other one. Yeah.
I was in like a second floor
core into conspiracy theory in that type
of shift for about a year and a half.
And then I just said, fuck it. I
got a great girl and getting a dog.
I don't got shit. I got, I got sick, I
got a dog for you. If you want a dog,
no dogs a whore or don't take his dog
in mind. Dogs are serious slut. My dog.
I actually, I finally, if we worked
with a trainer and we got it now,
it's all cool. And he came. How
long did, how long did it take for?
The check was wrong. Six months. Six
months. And did they train at your house?
When did you drop was I was a psycho
and like, no, seriously, like dogs,
dogs, they feed off of your fucking
energy. So you know, I'd watch games,
I slammed the table, you know, and I just,
it just in general that fucking the same
energy that I had when I was a kid, man,
we had these little west
Highland terriers, like we
turned them into maniacs.
This one. You really didn't think bit
me in my face. I had to get fucking see,
chill. You beat the kids. What do
you do? A, we would fuck with it.
We didn't know any better meet
the dogs. No, we didn't beat him.
We just thought piece of play the
glove game. The glove like a uh,
like a baseball glove. Fucking
wrestle with, I'll get to it. Yeah.
See Price. It's like we're
on fucking $10,000 pyramid.
Fucking Christ. Uh, a gardener's glove
and we were just fucking them in the
face and then he started biting too hard
and be like Fox,
then moved onto the boat.
We didn't realize we turned it into
a fucking maniac. We basically,
any psychologists who wanted to
see how fucked up my family was,
all we would have to do is walk in,
look at the dog and be like, wow.
It's cause the trickle down effect. It's
like what was happening to us as kids.
We did to each other and then
everybody did it to the fucking dog.
This house,
this house was,
I sh I gotta be careful how I say
this because they were nice people,
but the woman was a very
hot and a little bit older,
but you know, still hot like in a
MILF way and but super controlling.
And the man was just like this sort of
a meek guy who happened to be rich and
the woman had these fucking dogs and
this woman was a mean lady. She was me.
She would yell at her husband in front
of us and she had these dogs that which
fucking snap at everybody.
They would bite people a bit like three
different people in the ground people.
And I grew up with dogs. I grew
up in the pit bulls pit bulls. My,
my whole life I had crazy dogs.
So I saw these dogs and they came running
up to me like when I was in the house
and the dogs got right up to the mountain,
what's going on guys?
I'm gonna get my hand. And then
she goes, this is incredible.
They don't let anyone touch them. They
would pay your throat out by this time.
Okay, great. Owner and I'm like,
fuck is wrong with you. You've
got these crazy animals live in you.
They want to tear people's throats out.
When you invite them in your
house and you come into my house,
let them come up to you. Yeah, you
come to my house and I go, hey,
there's just say hi Johnny. Johnny will
come over wagging his tail. You pet him,
he'll kiss your face this cause he
recognizes you as a friend. You're,
you're in this group of Nice people.
The fuck is really, that's a,
that's an indicative of a creepy person,
right.
I was just fucking wound up. So the
dog, they feed off the fucking energy.
So the dog started getting wound up and
then it started growing and people on
the street and then I got nervous.
So then the dog would sense my nervous
system will growl a little bit,
fucking more. And it just, it just built.
And then I would be terrified walking down
the street with the thing and the dog.
And in the meanwhile is the dog would
come up on the couch whenever it wants.
It's just sort of running shit.
And I didn't know any of that shit.
But so we undid all of that.
Now the dog is totally fucking cool.
People come over, it's wagging its
tail and it all had to do with uh,
the way you were applying
with the energy that the,
I mean no I didn't do any of that,
that rough housing with the dog,
but the dog I've been doing in my act
is even if you rough house with a dog,
you got to bring their energy
back down to being chill.
You can't have them if this
heightened fucking thing. Right.
And then walk outside cause they fucking,
especially like pit bulls, that thing,
if you own one,
you have to address the fact that you
fucking own a dangerous breed because
people just said, Nah, she's the most
lovable, blah blah blah blah blah blah.
It's like yeah. And also has
ability to rip somebodies face off.
So I was having like panic attacks.
Like if this thing I've a bit,
somebody called like nerve
damage of fucked up their face.
Oh Deonte Deonte beyond getting sued.
It's the level of guilt I would have had.
So you know, uh, I knew, you know,
a couple people who had pit bulls and
they took him to this guy and they just
did a great job. But it was literally,
it was six fucking months of uh,
in your house or did they not know
he took the dog, first of all,
I took the dog for six months and then
you get it back a half a year later.
He's still so shocking. That dog,
he had him for like a month. No,
he had it for a month
and electrode the same,
should they did the data into your oma
putting neglect Trojans asshole? No, no.
He had it for a fucking month. The
whole month. It's great. Yeah as well.
Cause you got to chill the fuck out
because I've got this because uh, yeah,
it wasn't,
it wasn't cheap but it was way cheaper
than getting the living shit out of me
and him being guilt and fill in the guilt.
So we went through all of that bullshit
and now the dog is just like, it's,
it's cool as hell. He just trains it
all day every day. Now it's like, well,
the funny thing is it's like the dog.
The second he's around him and
we're removed from the equation,
it goes back and he's chilling.
He's in control and instantly was fine.
The dog was instantly did, the
problem was was us. We didn't know.
And now we were all fucking scared.
Anytime you would come over, all right,
you just blah blah. And everything
I was doing was fucking wrong.
And it just kept,
it just kept building the experience,
which would add to my paranoia.
So it just became a really bad situation.
But the second he went over
with him, you know, he was fine.
He was walking in with dogs. Everything
was cool. He had to learn like a cause.
It's walking into a totally
new environment, new set
of rules. We were gone.
It didn't feel like it had to protect
anybody. So the dog was instantly
fine. What he had to do was undo us.
It had nothing to do with the dog.
It was us four a.
And the reason why it took six months
was cause I'm on the road every other
fucking weak ones. Like would they, the
whole family grew from that experience?
I think so. I go from offering it.
It was awesome. It's very romantic.
It's good that there's someone
out there that can do that, man,
because there's a lot of
people that would say,
I wish it was cheaper because there's
a lot of people with fucking dangerous
dogs. There's a guy who lives
down the street from me.
His pit bulls are always out and he's
like, oh, they're nice. They're friendly.
Like get the fuck Outta here,
man. To, I've had pit bulls,
I've had a bunch of them.
They don't like other dogs.
If somebody else's dogs lose too,
like you didn't have a dead dog
in the street. It depends on,
it really depends on like if we wanted
to get another dog, we would have to,
as a female,
we'd have to get a male and you have to
get a pop in so they would have a mother.
So relationship. Absolutely right.
You do it that way. You don't,
you don't bring in another female. Yeah,
like my dog. Just it's personality.
It's not the kind of dog that you want
to walk with other dogs. Very possessive,
very jealous.
So it's something you have to keep in con,
but they're just like people,
they have different personalities
where I'm fucking a wound up psycho.
There's another guy who's just totally
fucking chill and wouldn't have had a
problem with the dog. The dog would
have become a chill dog. Yeah.
Do they do that show you're
watching a game and some
band? What do, what the fuck?
And then like they come up like,
yeah dude, what the fuck? You know,
they start getting into that mode and
then if you have a dog that's, you know,
bred to fight in a pit,
it's red show.
It's amazing that you could just buy that.
And then people,
I mean they're great dogs,
they're super friendly and super sweet
that you can go down to a shelter and
they just,
it's like just giving somebody a gun.
You don't even know what ended the
bullet comes in other than the guns,
like given him a monster to giving them
a wild monster that's going to be your
buddy. You know, you didn't even speak
English. She didn't even tell him, listen,
you can't eat kids. He can't even
fucking tell him shit. Do you understand?
I have a bank account
and this is how your dog,
how about you shouldn't fucking kill
people. He'd be a nice doggy, you know,
that's the end. See on the fucking
show, dude, I can't believe this.
He careful with pit bulls two hours,
two and a half hours.
We went on for a long time. But
you know what, it's always, uh,
it's always fun to have you on
Bro. You're, you're hilarious.
Your phone number stories I didn't even,
hype is a means of buddies of mine made a,
a short film and we just got into
the Tribeca film festival. Really?
It was it called cheat? Cheat.
Yeah. What's it about me,
Joe de Rosa and Robert Kelly.
Joe,
Bobby Kelly asked me to write
an article or other, um, uh,
uh, a chapter because you got, I guess
you guys are going to do a book on it now.
That story, something to go along with.
That book came out of that. Uh, yeah,
it's been this, it's been this
great thing. So, you know,
we wrote it and shot at ourselves
about a year ago and finally, you know,
started submitting it to festivals.
So we're in that thing.
So we're all really excited about.
Nice. So when can people see it? Uh,
while they can see it at the festival
if you live anywhere around there. Uh,
but then afterwards that we're striking
back at film festival is in Tribeca,
New York and Manhattan
and a there'll be a,
I think it's April 20th through like
May 3rd and then afterwards it will be
available for DVD or what
you're going to try to get it?
We haven't got to that point
yet. Yeah, I don't know how
that works. This is the first
thing we've ever done. So,
uh,
how many minutes is it like 1515 film.
So do you think you would put it online
and have it available online or how
would a, what would you do afterwards?
I have no idea. So it's cool. Would,
where would,
what started this just started talking and
yeah, I don't want to give away, like,
I don't want to give away the movie,
but basically it was one of those
deals where it was like three comedians
sitting around there was a fucking problem
and we just started brainstorming on
it and somebody was like, dude,
this is a movie. And then we,
I know we just fucking sat down and
wrote it and then, uh, awesome. Yeah,
it was really cool.
Now it's one of the best times I ever
had because we just put the money up
ourselves and shot at
ourselves and afterwards we
were trying to figure out why
we had such a great fucking
time and it's like, oh yeah,
there was no industry going.
Why doesn't he wear like a red
shirt and he can be like a plumber.
Well you that you were
there for the Chapelle show.
Did you get to experience any of them?
You are on a regular on that show, right?
I know I, I wasn't on the second
season, I was becoming a regular,
I only did five sketches, but I just
ended up being in five of the huge ones,
the racial draft,
the world series of dice.
Even like the Sam Jackson wanted
somebody that everybody loves.
And all I did was I just sat
there and got yelled at so easy.
I just took cotton and stuck it in my ear
and just let, let them yell. And he was,
and he was absolutely hilarious.
But as far as why the show
stopped and all that time, I mean,
I'm as much in the dark as a,
as you go.
I do know that he was going out and
trying to do with shows and everybody was,
you know, he couldn't get a word
out. Yeah, yeah. You know what,
that's my couch, motherfucker. They
believe all of that shit. So he, you know,
I have no idea.
But what I think is cool about it is
that you just have to killer fucking
seasons, you know, air tight to get back
to that expression rather than, you know,
there's,
there's certain shows that they probably
should acquit five seasons in and they
just kept making them.
I think if you gave Dave a ton of weed
and let them do whatever the fuck he
wanted to do, he would keep
cranking them out our, oh yeah,
he's perfect for that shit.
That blind racist that was
accidentally blind Klu Klux Klan Guy.
That was accident blackout.
That was at first, what was it?
Which one was that called? What was the
name of this catch? Clayton Bigsby. Yeah.
God Damn, that was brilliant.
Fucking brilliant. Yeah.
They just need to leave that guy alone.
When I did the fear factor sketch with
him, he was telling me that they were,
they were trying to tell him like how
many times he could say nigger and he
couldn't say nigger. And you got to
stop saying this to stop saying that.
And you know.
Well what happens is, is I think
when something becomes a success,
then everybody wants to try
and get that stink on it.
So that can be like I was the guy who
said to put the desk over there and blow.
Rather than you just go on
like, hey, you're killing
it. Just keep whatever that,
whatever the fuck you doing. Cause I know
like, like they, they thought that uh,
somebody on the show read me that
the industry notes for that, uh,
I'm Rick James Bitch sketch and they,
the overall thing was basically,
this is just a series of things
that aren't really funny.
Like they, they didn't get what was
going on. Like I remember when, uh,
when they were
doing that, Neal, I lived
like a like, I dunno, like,
like I could walk up to where
they were editing the thing.
And when they did the Rick James thing,
like Neil called me up, he's like, dude,
you got to come up here
and check this thing out.
I don't think we can talk to shit.
And I remember walking in there dying
laughing for like the first four minutes.
And I was just in awe. I was
like, dude, this is the greatest,
that's the greatest fucking
sketch of all time ever.
That shows the greatest gift show of
all time. Nothing even comes close.
Nothing comes close. I'll send her and
love, can't fuck with that. No, no.
Shows can fuck with that.
Yeah.
If I ever had that laugh reading quality
as far as like social commentary and
then just like ridiculous,
like silliness of the show when
fucking depressed because it kills me.
That fucking kills me too, is that he's
like, he's doing stand up and he like,
you know,
he'll announce on Thursday,
he's going to show at cobb's on Friday
and I'll do two shows and play bongos for
five hours. You know, it's like, I wish
that guy was like putting out specials,
you know, when she was putting
out DVDs and shit. You know,
I meet him twice in the last month.
What have you done would
you say on the comedy store,
which is on that the parlor.
And I saw him at the comedy store.
Uh, it's interesting the,
the direction he's going,
he's kind of going into more of a,
where it seems really organic, uh,
talking to the audience
and stuff like that.
But with bits kind of mixed in so you
don't even realize you're getting doing
like he's doing standup on you.
So it's weird. It's really weird.
And then he had some guys come up
and play music and he was like,
I kind of doing like singing and
rapping at points and stuff like that.
But again,
it felt like it wasn't planned.
It felt like you were getting a show
that no one else got to see. Right.
But then I talked to a couple of the other
mic, uh, comics and they're like, oh no,
no, this is, if you see a couple of these,
you'll see that this is exactly
what is act is now. Wow.
And it was kind of interesting. I
liked it. I thought it was cool.
I was entertained.
He pissed off.
A lot of people have jobs because he's
doing like these five hour sets and wait,
staff's going fucking nuts,
dude.
That's like do two shows
and do like three hours,
three and a half hours in what Dan was
some lamps. I mean how many fucking,
I don't know.
It's him.
And I remember when Dan Cook tried to
top that and he like fucking stayed on
stage for like eight hours or something
crazy. Was it seven? So that what it is.
And by the way,
the Guinness Book of World Records is
ridiculous because there's always some
retard out there with nothing to lose,
especially when it
comes to standup comedy.
Who the fucking get define
what standup comedy.
You can get some complete sociopath to
stand on stage for three days in a row
and just shit himself and, and piss all
over the fucking stage. And then he wins.
Flagpoles yeah, that's both. Stay up
there. They, you know what they should be,
there should be some like laugh meter
and once you just start running out of
jokes and just said [inaudible] the
lights go out of the house on a minutes
where you can play with the crowd. Yeah.
A certain amount of times you can say,
so what else is going on?
I guess you just get like a red
flag and it's just like, dude,
this isn't stand up zero airplanes
through there. Yeah. It's like,
it would be funny if the less you laughed,
the last the audience laughed,
the brighter the lights in
the room got. Yeah. You know,
and to let you know when all the lights
are on and the show's not dark anymore.
It's like, it's like can get off
like a video game. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like that guitar hero
starts going,
Huh,
your spotlight dims your spotlight
dems and the audience gets brighter.
Yeah.
So if people want to listen to a bill,
Bill also has a great podcast called the
Monday morning podcast that's available
on iTunes and it's not on
stitcher anymore. Right. You
pull it off stitcher. Yeah,
I took it off. Yeah. So it's not a lot of
controversy with the stitcher APP. Yeah.
They just saw that apparently people are
getting stitcher and I back it up 100%
I think it's fucking awesome.
Be able to go in your car and just have,
be able to choose podcasts and listen
to them automatically, you know,
streaming kind of problem I had,
they just took mine, never told me,
and then was selling advertising and
they will make and fucking money. Whoa.
Which is, yeah, that's not fucking cool.
So that's illegal to sue them to stop.
And then they sent me an offer, which is
hilarious. It's like someone stole your,
your fucking car and then you show up
guy and give him my car back. Like,
hey look, I put some rims on it. You know,
you want a piece of that. It's like, yeah,
well apparently there's a
big move to get off of it.
Marin was talking to me about it yesterday
and Greg Fitzsimmons called me about
it and Greg Fitzsimmons at
the same situation that you
had when they put it shut
off.
So he said it was a lot of people that
are going to cut me in on the average of
what about all the money you've
already made off for the fucking thing.
He didn't get you. Yeah, exactly. Like
that Internet thing. We're just like, hey,
you know everybody can
take everybody's shit.
I don't think there's a problem with that.
Brian [inaudible] free content and
they're selling advertisement on it now.
I have no problem with it.
How come?
Because they're offering or the
service they're offering. Lift My,
if my listeners want to drive around
and be able to stream my show,
I'm not offering that on my website.
So let them do it and I offered online.
How do you drive around? You have
to throw it on mine. On dream it.
You can stream it off of
your mobile phone. No,
you can go to iTunes and I like look at,
look it.
This is the thing about what I'm saying
though. You can't do that. You if you,
if you're driving in your car
right now and you were like,
I want to listen to Joe Rogan's
podcast from four weeks ago.
You're streaming something that I created,
you got to kick me money for that.
You just take not just streaming that.
That'd be like if I started a radio
station and I started playing it,
but let me finish and I
didn't pay anybody. I didn't
play any of the musicians,
but they're not putting advertising
in the show. Yeah, they are. Nope.
I listened to stream of that.
I showed you miss,
why are they coming to the website?
They're not,
they're not putting advertising
in the show, not adding.
Know that they're not adding ads in
the shorter guy saying that they are.
Because I think on stitchers
website where like on the Apps,
they have advertising and they're
getting all these hits cares about that
because, because they're
making money on my stuff. Do.
People aren't going to the website
to just just sit there and listen to,
to streaming. They're going, they're
listening to content. It's like, dude,
it's like a fucking network.
Yeah. But if they let me finish,
you have a production house and they
make shows and to p, it's not like, oh,
I have a TV show,
so I'm just going to show you a TV show.
I'm not gonna pay any of
the creators of the show.
I don't have a problem with
them or with what they're doing.
But you don't just take it and not pay
somebody. That's true. Yeah. You're gonna.
If you're gonna make money off of it,
you have to kick somebody some money.
And how even you use youtube, whenever
you have a, that gets a lot of hits,
they offer you, you know, you can, Hey,
you can sell ads on this and
we'll give you money. I mean,
I gotta offers on my videos all the time.
I'm not saying like what their
business model is not a bad thing.
It's the way they went about it. It's like
if they said, hey listen, I want to put,
if they approached me first and said,
listen, we got this great model,
it's gonna allow people to listen to
streaming the thing or whatever and you
know, we're gonna, we're gonna advertise,
we're going to kick you some money. Fine,
but don't just start doing it and
making money. Then out of nowhere,
I find out about it like six months later,
a year later after you've made all that
money and then I'm like, what the fuck?
And I go to take it off and
now that I'm taking it off,
now you're going to offer me money.
That's fucked up.
That's not how you do business. You
could also think of it this way though,
to stream stitcher has their
own community as strip stickers,
like a Facebook or a Twitter, and so
when they, when you have a show on there,
they're also introducing you to their
whole community. You have to ask.
I know,
but what if I'm signed on for is you're
making it seem like stitcher is this
entity that is amazing that people are
just going to sit there and stare at
stitcher. Well, it's, they're going
there for the content. I know.
I'm not saying that they don't provide a
service and I'm not saying any of that,
but for them to take my shit and just
put it up there and make money off of it,
I'm not saying that they have
to give me 100% of the money.
I'm saying you just can't just,
you can't just,
you can't just take his stuff and copy
it and then start selling ads on it on
your thing. You can't do that. Well,
I agree. But you have thought sue.
He can say no, I know, but listen, I
listened. They also like as an example,
stitcher is now putting in all the brand
new Fords and also with a couple of
other car dealer or companies have now
added Stitcher as inside there, uh,
cars now.
Why?
Because now it's where they're moving
away from Sirius radio and Xm radio until
Internet connected because of the content
and the amount of hits that they're
getting.
And that has nothing to do with stitcher.
That has to do with Joe
Rogan's fucking hilarious.
Greg Fitzsimmons fucking hilarious.
Mark Marin is doing these great pot.
That's why people are going
there. I guess to me, um, if I,
if I could have my shit fucking in every
single Ford car that people can listen
to and it's a, it's a part of the
car now. She was like, you know,
what's your choice? You're
pitching, you're pitching
what people on that side too,
which is the pimp game where they talk
about the exposure and all this great
exposure and then the only way for us
to make money off of the exposures are
people going to your shows and people
buy your cds. Yeah. Let me finish.
I still have to get on a fucking
plane and fly to Kansas City.
While that was motherfuckers
get to sleep in their own bed,
they don't have to leave. You
know what I mean? No, Huh?
What I'm saying?
That's what's you're acting like
you're acting eats toast. No, wait.
What you're saying is, is your,
your, your, your, your debt.
That bullshit where artists get paid in
exposure is the big pimp game in fucking
Hollywood. It's this character.
They have you changed.
We're going to stick you on this. We're
not going to give you any fucking money,
but everybody's going to hear this and
then you're going to go to Kansas City
and Jesus Christ, the whole, you're
going to play with a fucking royals play.
Meanwhile, they're making all this fucking
money. Well that's the kind of you,
and you got to be like
fucking what it would dif.
You got to fucking pack up and
go fly out to go get your money.
They're sitting at home raking in
all this shit and this is the thing.
You are providing the fucking content.
They're providing the service so
they should get paid for the service.
You should get paid for your content.
That's all I'm saying.
This should be a business, Mary. If you
just don't take the fucking content.
If your content with some
money free already though,
your content for free on iTunes.
Yeah,
but you can't put it on your own
application. That's, which is my choice.
It on iTunes and I have, and I have the
choice. I have the choice to decide.
My podcast is fucking free.
I could sit there and I could decide if
I want to charge money for it, but dude,
it's mine. It's mine and it's my decision.
It's not yours to just fucking take.
And then because you know,
I've been busting my ass and work on
this thing for fucking three years and
everybody wants to go see it and now you
just take it and make a ton of fucking
money off him and you don't even tell me.
Didn't call me on.
I don't think that they're making
a shitload of money at all.
I don't have stitchers.
It's not really making a shit.
It doesn't matter if they're
making $2 you have to give me one,
but you can't just do so I just make
money off people's stuff. You're,
you're pretending that they're not
selling content. They have a dream.
I listened to my shit on
stitcher everyday. I've
never heard of ad once. Okay,
so it's not seeing the ads. The ads are
on the, there's no ads playing during my,
on my podcast.
There's No ads before or after my podcast.
So to me saying no problem with stitcher
and they're not making any money off me
directly. Okay. That's you. But I
see, I don't know how we're buying it.
How you're saying that they're
making money or anything.
I opened the stitch up right
house, open up, stitch it.
Right now I find my pint that
they do those people ads for free.
You're confused. Like you listen to
a radio station. Let Brian Finish.
Let me do they have listened to a radio.
I don't remember every hearing or seeing
one SME. Listen to me. All right. Okay.
When you listen to a radio station,
they don't play an ad during a song,
but you listened to the radio station
because the play in the kind of music you
want to listen to. That's why. Are you
listening to duty? Yeah, I'm listening.
So that's why if you play a
band song on the fucking radio,
the band gets paid. Okay? You get paid.
Do you want to stay in that are saying
that there's no ads on this? So,
so I'm going to comedy right now.
I'm typing in comedy.
Now I'm going to comedians.
Here's comedians right up here.
Now there's a a little banner
that pops up the very bottom,
but best make some money. Does squad
him at the very top little banner,
various money. I know, but Facebook makes
money off of you, but you're on Facebook.
Are you going to sue Facebook and pull
off your stuff on Facebook that makes
shitloads wait a hold up.
And he had a blog and they copied his
blog entries and put it on Facebook.
Then started selling advertising show.
You chose to be on Stitcher, right? No,
I didn't ask. You know, didn't I? That's
the whole point of what he's saying.
Brian is that high.
I chose to be on Facebook and I
choose what I put to go to put up.
I did not choose to be on Stitcher,
stitcher took my shit and put it.
See No advertisement before
this is me talking. Okay.
Brian, he's targeting. Yeah,
Dude. It's like I'm trying to
make, I'm trying to explain it.
We had it right there and you're so
convinced of your argument. I mean,
if you're totally conviction of
argument, I'll just stop right now. No,
I don't think you understand
a lot of like the Internet,
like I understand that you don't want your
MP three on here so you can tell them,
yes,
I don't want you on here,
but stitcher is not like
selling advertisements during
your show. They're doing,
they're pretty much doing
what it's available.
You want them to give you this free.
I already read on the Internet.
I answered this like three minutes ago.
You're just not listening to me.
You're not listening to me. I realize
that they're not playing it during it.
I said, when you listen to a radio
station, they play ACDC back in black.
They don't play a wool light
commercial in the middle of it,
but in between the songs they advertise
and the amount of listeners that are
radio station gets is not
because of the commercials.
It's because of the music that is there.
The artists that put that out there that
that's why that the bands get played.
They get a portion of the advertising.
That's how business is done.
I don't have a problem with that.
I would love to be on stitcher
if they did it the right way.
If they approached me and said,
listen, this is what we're doing.
We're going to sell advertising.
We're making this amount of money,
we're going to kick you that.
I would've done it in a second,
but the thing is they just
took my podcasts and all my
listeners who go on there
because they like what I do and then
they made money off of that because
inbetween on the side of their website
and that shit that you saw at the bottom,
they're making money off of that and they
didn't kick me any money until you got,
you got caught. And I said, does keep
people from getting it off of iTunes.
It's definitely the only negative
part about it in my opinion,
is that it takes a hurts your iTunes,
the numbers,
but like as any single
website that you used people,
if you give something out
for free on the Internet,
you can consider stitcher to be just
an MP, three player. Right. And, and,
and any application on here. And
I was like, at different numbers,
they're making money off of it.
Look,
I put it out there and everybody
downloads it and it's for free. Right.
But the second you take it and
you start making money off of it,
it's the same way.
Like if you see both of your points,
I see both of your points.
I do see Brian's point that he did pull
up the application and the only ad was
this little tiny ass banner that
I'm making money off of that. Yeah,
you could say that. That might be just
enough to keep your sites growing.
How much money you think that little
banner, how much, how much does the APP,
let me ask you this dude. How do you,
how do you run a business? The Free App,
how do you run a business
that makes no money?
Because they are selling their
programs at to put companies like Ford.
So now you buy a Ford and they
have a stitch you up in there.
So it's like a serious rate. No. And why
is for getting in business with them?
Because the s the future of radio is
podcasting. It's not satellite radio.
It's not [inaudible] is the thing.
Yeah but I'm doing a podcast.
How come for doesn't come to me?
He came to these guys cause they stuck
them all together and it's because of all
the hits that Joe gets. All the
fans that I have, all the fans at,
all these people have these
guys stuck it all into one,
but they should have come to us and
said this is we want to do and get in
business with us.
You just don't hijack everybody
shit and then stick it on there.
Start selling advertising banners on the
bottom and then getting contracts with
Ford because they're
looking at their website,
they're seeing all the hits
that they won't get an RSS feed.
What you have when you have a podcast,
so you have an RSS feed.
What that RSS feed means is that every
single thing you're letting everyone you
want to play your MP three players.
So there's websites that will grab your
RSS feed and just and put it on their
website. That's what ours says. You're
sharing it. You're giving me for free.
Right. But this is the thing is still
count one a load from an RSS feed counts.
The big argument is a Twitter,
you know,
or rather then then take the free thing
and then start making money off it.
You have to pee. It's common as
business. There's business one on one.
You have to pay the person. If I'm giving
away for free, you can just take it.
You can't just go out.
Well,
maybe they tried to do it this way and
just stitcher also has a way to to pay
their artists now. They had a pay
thing. Now they've started a couple of,
a couple of months ago.
Bill was right when I was saying they
should have come to me and say, listen,
we'd like your podcast. We've seen
you're getting this amount of hits.
We want to put it on here.
We have some advertising and
we'll kick you some of it. Dude,
I would be on stitcher. I haven't done
that to you. Never. You sure? Oh yeah,
he's positive, bro. You can. They'd
come to me. They've come to me to do it.
Two months ago they came to me too.
I allowed them to think.
[inaudible] never came to me. They never
came to him. They never put it into me.
They just took my shit. See, that's the
thing. If they came to me, I would've,
I would've, I wouldn't have had a
problem. Our pocket, our podcast is fake,
came to me when my lawyer sent him a
cease and desist and then they go, oh,
you want, what if we gave your percentage
of this money that we've been making?
Hmm. Now if it had nothing
to do with my podcast,
they wouldn't have offered me
that. The, I think a precedent has
established once and it becomes really
profitable. And right now it's not.
And I totally agree with you that you
can't take your stuff and just put it up
there without asking and then put
advertisement on the application.
Even if it's indirectly,
you know,
if there's a certain amount
of ads that you know, you,
you just get every time
you go to stitcher, but one
podcast gets a, you know,
a really high number of downloads,
like your Monday morning podcast does.
Well that's, you're, you're selling that,
you're selling the Monday morning podcast.
That's what you're selling when
you're advertising. You know, I,
I totally get that.
But the way,
the way I look at podcasting in
the first place is, um, I want,
I agree that it's good to have,
you know,
sponsors that pay for things and you
can, you know, you could, you know,
make money off the show and it's good.
It's good to get paid for someone
downloading it and listening to it.
But for me what's important
is that people get it.
That's what's important for me.
It's important that it is the reason why
it's free on my website as well as free
unused stream as well as free on
iTunes as well as on stickers.
Yeah. USTREAM is making
shit off of it right now.
I don't have a problem with that.
I mean they have to pay for bandwidth.
They take care of us and I
don't, to be honest with you,
I don't know. I like Youtube.
I found out that [inaudible] no,
you streaming the video. It's,
we're doing this right now. This is not
right. No, I don't, I don't do video.
I don't do video a youtube account,
but this is the most, I'm actually
trying to get advertising on,
on a,
on my website. I mean, I
mean all my podcasts, I don't
have a problem with that,
but this is like, this is, this is,
this is the game of this business where
it's like the artist's does the work and
then the, the business guys come in and
they give you the fucking Heisman. Right?
I mean, I mean it's right through
the whole business with those guys.
Those guys who made fucking Lord
of the rings never got paid.
They made $6 billion. They had to
sue to get their fucking money.
What do you mean go look it up?
They got the whole fucking thing though.
That was always the lawsuit.
Is that one of those things where they
have Hollywood type of counting where
they show losses, man? Yeah, we have,
we had $4 billion in whiteout
in 9 billion in, in paper clips.
So we're still not in profit and fucking,
you know,
the director doesn't get paid and yeah,
it was a huge fucking
lawsuit and they just, they,
and then whatever the conglomerate was,
they decided that it was cheaper to
just get sued. They paid themselves out,
then they imploded the
thing and just left.
And these guys and it was total
is totally fucking legal. Wow.
It's an interesting thing. The, this
whole podcast thing though, isn't it? How,
you know, I mean, basically what
we're doing right now, as you know,
at any moment when we put one of
these things out during the week,
a quarter million people download
this fucking thing. And that's a,
that's a big number of human beings
that you could just reach on your own.
Don't you find that like shows or more
packed with like your real fans now than
ever before? Do you find that? I find it,
it's a combination of doing an opening.
Anthony doing morning radio,
my specials and my podcast
people definitely listened
to the podcast and that.
And, uh, yeah, no,
it's a great way to get
out and have people, uh,
come out to your shows. But it's,
it's one of those things where like,
I don't do that shit where I'm getting
paid in exposure and you're taking all
the fucking money.
And then so for the rest of my life,
in order for me to get
the fruits of my labor,
I got to go fly to fucking
Tennessee when it's like I'm,
I'm doing a fun doing a
fucking radio show here.
Radio guys don't go on the
fucking road for some reason.
It just all goes back to,
but then when you do your monkey dance,
you get paid and it's like,
so no value is being put on the fact
when you go and don't get money.
I see their error in judgment.
I see their error in judgment and I see
the wooded truant doing is they take
something that's already free and they
make a device that allows you to get it
to people that wouldn't ordinarily get it.
But it does when I didn't want it.
His point that when I do radio, I'm
flying, I'm in there, I fly in there,
I do radio and I'm hyping my shows.
That's the point of it.
My podcast is not hyping my shipping you,
my podcast is my radio show.
It's my radio show. That's what
this is a fucking radio show dude.
Right as they call it a pocket.
It's my radio show you.
I can't just hijack the stern show and
the and put it on my site and just start
selling advertising and then when he
tells me to cease and desist, go, hey,
can I let you in on some of this
money? And then I go, well Howard,
you're fucking huge man.
Why don't you go fly and stand on a stage
and tell jokes and Kansas
City you'll get paid that way.
I see what you're saying. Yeah, I see.
Like I understand like it's, it's,
it becomes an issue. If it takes a
while. I would love to be in business,
those guys with their exposure, but you
just have to do it the right way, dude.
You don't just take it and make money and
wait till I find out about it and then
offer me a cut.
I think when you,
when it comes to podcast and
certain things on the Internet,
especially when it comes
to RSS feeds, uh, that,
that that's just common for the Internet.
Like there's companies,
there's Zoe now that you're saying
though is because this not RSS feeds or
you're dealing with,
you're dealing with someone copying a
thing and then sending it out through an
application, which is completely
different is RSS feeds.
You're going to get an
account of every doubt.
He is presented the two classic arguments
that they do when they fuck artists,
they stay talk about exposure,
what great exposure this is Nevins
and then suddenly let me finish.
And then secondly, he did,
he did the whole, this is
just the way it's done. Like,
you know, like when, when a,
when a manager hands you that contract
with this automatically renews.
If I get you one, one thing at the chuckle
hut and you say, dude, this is bullshit.
And it's like, no, everything's
negotiable. You're right. It's negotiable.
If you have an RSS feed as an example,
if you have something on your ear,
you have something on most websites,
wordpress, even RSS feed, right.
There's programs like there's one
called Flipboard on the IPAD. What it,
what it does is it collects RSS
feeds and it's it repackages.
It makes your website kind
of look like a magazine,
but they sell kind of mix advertising in
there, here and there. You know there's,
there's,
there's programs that do that same thing
that stitcher doing except the only
thing that stitchers doing is
different is taking it off your server,
putting it on their server so it
doesn't affect your bandwidth.
That's a big issue. And it's not affecting
the bandwidth. This is my number.
I'm not confused. No, you've
explained it like three times. Dude,
I understand what it is. I know,
but they're not directly like,
like I'm trying to say is that
they're not like these little banner
advertisements. Like that's not making
millions of dollars. It doesn't matter.
But it's making its affecting
the downloads from iTunes,
which affect his numbers yet.
But you can get those numbers from
stitcher and if you don't want to be on
Stitcher, you can tell them to
take you off a stitcher. Yeah.
But even if you watch this
one, numbers lie and, and I,
and I told them and then they fucking
obviously, so this is the funny thing,
obviously they're making some money
if they offered me to stay. Okay.
And I also know you can't pay your
rent unless you're making money.
I'm not saying that those guys
are millionaires over there.
What I'm saying is that that's not the
way you conduct business. That's wrong.
That's, you can't do
that, man. That's wrong.
You can't just take somebody's creative
shit and just start making money off of
it and not, and not paying them. I
don't underst like that. That said,
bizarre Internet thing where
people feel that because they can,
they can see it and they
can put it on their site,
that they own it and then have the right
to do whatever they want with it and
make money off it and not paying anybody.
I'm not being a dick here too.
I'm really not. I'm just, I'm
just asking to go about it.
I would love to be on
stitcher. It in a, in a,
in a functional business model.
I don't want to be on it where it's
just you just fucking swipe it and make
money and wait for me to
find out about it. Well,
one thing you should
definitely do is take off your,
your podcast off of your RSS feed so that,
that,
cause you're not only a stitcher doing,
that's about probably a hundred different
companies are using your RSS feed and
your MP3 to make money right now.
Okay.
So you have to take probably
a hundred people daily,
over a hundred companies that are using
his shit. To me, one of the women,
he got things like stitcher.
There's so many websites that we'll
play your MP three days on it and have
banner ever talking about too. We're
talking about what's right and wrong.
You just basically said,
well you busted this drug dealer,
there's another hundred drug dealers
out there doing it. It's like,
I'm not saying that there
aren't other people doing it.
I'm saying why I'm not on
stitcher anymore. Yeah.
But what I'm saying is that that's
why the RSS means on the Internet.
If you're putting out an RSS feed,
you're pretty much saying, all right,
this is an unprotected work that I am
sending out for you guys to have. Yes.
Do whatever you want.
No, I'm not saying that.
I'm not saying that you can
then go make money off of it.
I'm saying this is free. Here you go.
All right, well that's what I'm saying.
You to take off your RSS
feed off your website, Brian,
because they're profiting off the point.
I'm not missing the point.
I'm not missing quite,
that's what an RSS feed is and
that's mean that you're pretty much,
it's like an intendant advertisement.
This is my injuries.
What you're doing is you're telling me
what I'm thinking, what my intent is. No,
no. I'm just saying what an RSS feed
is. We know what an RSS feed is.
It's just something that allows
people to download something.
It's an automatic download.
You're saying that because I,
I was saying that sites that I'm on that,
yeah,
but you can't sell the advertising.
Usually someone's content
and sell advertising.
I don't know why that's so
hard for you to understand.
If they're not directly selling content
advertising towards your content.
They're there. That's what I'm
saying. Like the, the RSS feeds.
There's websites that are playing
his MP3 right now. Gone there
but you don't even know.
It's like,
I don't know exactly when you're
using you're shitty logic.
They're selling advertising and they're,
they're using [inaudible] radio so you
don't put on the radio station because of
the fucking advertising.
It's the bands that bring you there.
Like these guys play the music I want.
That's why the bands get play.
People are going to stitch here so
you have a problem with youtube too.
Then do you have videos on Youtube?
This is one of these guys like this.
This is going to be those guys where
it's just like you can't make a point
because he's RSS feeds are
already thinking of his
next point and he just wants
to be right. No, I'm just saying
what the west with RSF seats,
if you don't want your shit like
distributed and like made money off,
like you don't have an
RSS feed on your website.
Rss Feed for your website is for other
websites to grab and use your content for.
No, it's not. It's to get shit vacations.
No, it's the download shit for free. It's,
it's something that allows you to keep
up with people as they put out podcasts.
[inaudible], stitcher does stitcher
grabs your RSS feed and repackages no,
it doesn't dry out your MP three you're
wrong and it gets your MP three and then
sends it out through its own application.
[inaudible] top 100% wrong
and, but there's no way to
convince them because he's,
he's totally of his argument. Okay.
Yeah, it totally convinced of it,
Brian. The point is they're not saying
you're a bad person down at yourself.
You cannot listen.
You use the youtube argument and it's
a shitty argument and here's why. If,
if fucking youtube was stealing bill
burrs shit and putting it on Youtube and
then selling ads, that would work.
That would be like, Hey, what the fuck?
You can't have bill [inaudible]
but youtube is fans.
It's some kid in Nebraska that things
bill bursts hilarious and he watches his
special on comedy central and he takes
his computer and he edits or 10 minute
chunk and he throws it up on Youtube and
then she had been to John with exact no
problem.
That's completely different.
It's bad enough when I have a DVD coming
out in the second, somebody sees it,
then they put it on that. But I
understand now it's like, okay,
the DVD thing is over now.
Like I get that thing but this,
this is where the problem comes
is you then take my content,
okay and then start advertising off
of it and you don't fucking pay me.
That's the thing.
I understand that my shit's going to
end up on on the Internet and people are
going to get it for free and
that's just the way things are now.
I don't have a problem
with that. The, the,
the big fucking hurdle is when you take
it and then you start making money on
application, then have as you start making
money off your arguments completely.
Yeah. There's a reason why they came
back to me when I took it down and,
and offered me a cut and there's a
reason why they didn't want me to take it
down because I have listeners who
go there and when they go there,
they see the ad and they read it.
And in the advertising world,
that means while we get
enough guys looking at it,
they're going to fucking buy something.
But if they're going there because they
like your podcasts or they're like my
podcast, that's, that's why they have
to kick you a little bit of money.
[inaudible] people want to say shit.
I'm not saying like their
website is fucking awesome
the way they do business is
not in the youtube argument that the
thing about youtube that's crazy as the,
even though the kids are putting bill
burrs podcast or bill burrs a, you know,
standup mp3s or clips from a movie,
that's funny.
They're getting sued by all these
people that own that switch.
I wouldn't let the kids hold down.
That's one of those things where if
stitcher wasn't making any money and just
want to fucking throw it out there,
I wouldn't give a shit.
It's the fact that you're
making money off my podcast.
You've got to give me some money.
Those kids who take my my specials and
put them all over the fucking youtube,
I love it. That's fucking great.
I have no problem with that.
If they were somehow figured
out a way to make money,
you have to fucking pay me a certain
portion and I respect the fact that you
come up with the business
model that makes that,
cause I don't have the business model,
but you still,
you know the content is the model
of start charging for your podcast.
What's that? The model is
you start charging for your
podcast. What do you mean?
That's pretty much how you have to,
if that is or if you protect
yourself and protect your MBA real.
I want to have that of ads.
That's what I want to have.
But when I've had on a chart and I don't
want to have somebody take my podcast
and, and have advertising around it
and that type of shit and make money,
not tell me they take on my podcast, earn
money and not give me any of the money.
That's all I'm saying. I don't
have any problem. I, I'm,
I would love to be in business
with those guys. Like if they just,
if they fucking did it the right way,
they didn't.
So I just had them take it down. I
mean it's just normal business. Yeah.
I mean I think eventually that there's,
everybody has got saying that eventually
I won't be back up on stitcher cause
they already offered me something.
But what I'm saying,
the reason why I took it down
because what they did was not right.
That's just not how you do business.
It's stealing.
I agree. I agree. Our situation's
totally different. I, uh,
agreed to be on stitcher cause my, my, uh,
my way of looking at it is I just want
more people to get the podcast and are
only advertisement that we have is by the
fleshlight. And I have no idea. I mean,
having them on Stitcher,
in my opinion,
that's good for the
fleshlight is good for that.
Then people who want to read or they
what they want to sell advertising and on
my podcast and they want to
do a 50, 50 split. And I'm
like, dude, that sounds cool.
My feeling is that I'm going to happen,
bring in my own advertisers,
you know,
and I've got some other people that
I'm looking at as far as advertisers.
It's gotta be something
that I think is valid some,
and I'm just going to have him just
advertise the podcast and you can put it
wherever the fuck you want, man.
Put it anywhere. I don't care.
What's important to me is
that it gets out there,
which is exactly how I did these shows in
Gotham, in uh, in New York this weekend.
And I had fucking four hours
sleep in two days. I mean,
I was exhausted and I had to do two shows,
but the fucking crowds were so good.
It was so intense, man.
And when I asked them like,
how many you guys listen to the podcast?
It was like fucking 99% it was crazy.
Like it's, it's an audience of
podcast fans now. It's, it's,
it's a totally different audience,
which it's not just stand up fans or
not just fans of, of, of, you know,
of um, MMA, UFC fans. It's people
that are fucking fans of the podcast.
And so it's,
to me it's invaluable and the most
important thing is that the most people
possible can get it for free.
But I completely see your argument and
I think you're absolutely right to be
upset that someone downloaded your stuff.
And even if it's just a little pop up
banner, if you're making money off that,
it's the same as the youtube
argument. You know, you have to,
well, and this is the thing about it was
unless somebody told me it was on there,
I was never going to know. Right.
Because they didn't come to me.
Right. Yeah. That's
not cool. It's just be,
it would be just as if
youtube came and sorted,
download your stuff off TV and putting
it online. Well, Hey, he was on TV.
It was free. But no, it
had ads on TV and you know,
now you're just putting it in this list.
It does. The thing that the, the,
the big hurdle is when you start
making money off of my shit. Yeah.
That's the thing. But it's like if
people see me on TV and they download,
they put it up there.
I don't give a fuck if you don't make
time players and make some money off
windows media player makes money off
your shirt just by playing your stuff.
You know all this crap.
Is this like just how the Internet works
and how the Internet works ads while
you're stepping up in Windows Media
Player, there's advertising all evidence.
Windows Media Player, it's banners was
playing and stuff. No, no, no. You,
you windows media player can
only download some. Yeah.
That's readily available for free
and you play it from somewhere.
You have to download a file
and then play it on windows
and it's providing a service. Like I can
already have people listen to my shit.
Don't stop on on stitcher.
They can listen to what Brian let him
know and he had a can't explain RSS feeds
thought you explained it 100,000 times.
We know exactly.
You're saying do it and you
don't understand that you
should get paid for your
work. You don't get that for some
reason. You feel like like when I,
when I give it out for free
now that you shouldn't Brian,
they're making money off something that's
available for free. You can't do that.
You can't make money off. Someone's
constantly got money. Let's go,
let's go. Let's go this route. I mean,
why are you [inaudible] I'm trying
not to [inaudible] up attitude man.
I understand that NFL football on
fucking NBC, I watch NFL football.
I'm not allowed to record that and then
go send the fucking game up to other
people and make money off of it,
out for free and then the that they do
give it out for features of player is a
player player RSS feeds and advice.
Stop repeating yourself. That's why
I'm trying to fucking stop talking.
What you say has already
been refuted by both of us.
We both know what an RSS feed is.
We both know football is free on
network teachers not selling stitcher.
Listen to bill. Birds get come
here and listen to his podcast.
The Fuck Day are there selling gaming
God player out that collects RSS feed in
place and making money. No reason
why Adam Carolla Greg Fitzsimmons.
Everybody wants to pull
their shit off of it.
There's no reason if everyone's crazy
because everyone's crazy that they're
making my iTunes numbers.
It hurts their iTunes numbers would
cost them money and advertisement.
That's a big deal.
You're telling us what we're thinking.
I've been telling you for
45 bucks why I take it off,
but it's not like stitcher is making
money off of your podcast and selling you
into their their servers. They're giving
a free player out and that's all it is.
A free player sell Brian. Huh?
What does a free player have on it?
A collects RSS feeds off the Internet.
Stop, stop, stop. This RSS talk,
what is it like a podcast,
podcasts and his podcasts.
Flex arts as feet but as
podcast and it sells ads.
It sells ads. It has a banner
that pops up in the player.
Yes and sells. It, sells
their services, is collect,
see that they want to listen to Joe
Rogan reflect, stop repeating yourself.
[inaudible]
first of all,
understand you're yelling like a
little child [inaudible] me and saying,
we just disagree with you and we're using
logic and you're not getting angry out.
I think the best example is when a
baseball game or a football game,
it's on network TV. That's free. Not going
to fucking TV. Network TV is free. Okay.
You're not allowed to record
it and then start selling it.
Putting it on a player that they
had at the end of every single,
even if you include the advertisements,
you're not allowed to do that.
You can't just have your own TV thing.
It's a new format.
I can record the thing and have some
friends come over and watch the fucking
thing.
That's no big deal,
but the second I start charging people
to come through the door to watch this
game didn't provided, you know, all my
friends didn't have TVs. Then it's, yeah,
it's like,
no,
you're making money off our shore.
Taking that show and like playing it
at a bar on a VHS tape and causing,
you know, costing people do judge
and charging them to get in trouble.
I see your point and I see
where Brian's coming from.
I know what you're trying to say,
Brian.
I think you're just a little emotionally
tied up in this argument anyway. Okay,
well I'm just,
I'm trying to pursue things over and
not have you be a little child here.
I'm not seeing it now.
I'm considered a child.
I'm a considerate chow now you guys,
you guys, I can't talk about it though.
I can't be,
can't talk about him and just like I'm
talking to my mom about email right now.
No, it's not. It's like
we're talking to a challenge.
Just getting condescending attitude,
not ascending man.
Like you're talking to your
mom about email. You clearly
are being condescending.
Look,
you could be,
the fourth hour will be the best
fucking hours or minutes until it,
let's read this bitch, ride this
bitch right into the rocks and no,
I didn't think I was going to prom
with rush hour traffic. Well we were,
we started to stopping an hour ago and
somehow we've been talking about stitcher
and internet. Use your illusion
one and two podcast. Listen,
it's all good folks. You
know, to spicy Brian's point.
I know Brian Likes stitcher and he
loves the APP and I see what he's saying
about if you put something out there,
people are going to take it.
But I also absolutely see bill's point.
You can't just download
the stuff and then use it.
Limewire why wouldn't you love limewire?
It's sell free fucking shit. Exactly.
Yeah. At the end of the
day, the service is corrupt.
The beautiful thing about the Internet
is that you can put things out there and
you can use, uh, use, you know,
this format to get more people to
watch your shows and get more people.
But if you're going to sell ads, I agree
with you. You gotta, you gotta get paid.
I mean, it's no different than radio.
It's no different than television.
It's no different than any other service
that you're providing that people
profiting off. And that was my thing.
As long as they just came to me.
And just said, listen, we want to put
it on him. You provide this service.
We're going to sell the advertising.
We'll give you a little piece of it. Yeah,
because we know people aren't
coming here stare at our website.
They're actually coming here to listen
to your show that you produce and you
create, but I agree with Brian
Lapointe, money as an internet realist.
I totally agree with Brian's point
that you put something on an RSS feed.
You're just allowing people to download
it for free and they can probably pretty
much do whatever the fuck they
want with it, but they don't know.
Short of trying to make money out of it.
Yeah,
we got three minutes, but people sell
heroin. That doesn't mean it's legal.
All right, three minutes.
Yeah, we heard you bro.
We're going to have three minutes
of silence and see if you can cry.
I know that cry. It's just, it never,
I can't even talk about it. Yeah,
you can't talk to us.
I started getting,
I says we don't agree with your point
of view. There's a lot of that upset.
You don't understand. My point of view
and then every time I tried to explain it,
you say you're repeating yourself. Let
me tell you a point of view. Right?
Right now you're saying it's my
fault for putting it out there.
I put it out there and I put it on on
this they RSS feed and that gives it out
to anybody. It's your fault. I'm
saying if you want to stop it,
then don't have an RSS feed out there
because that's what it's for. Hey,
if you don't want to get shot in the head,
don't go out of the house.
The end Monday morning podcast
is available on iTunes. Uh,
follow him. Bilber, B I.
L L B U R R on Twitter follow Red Band,
r e d B,
a n on Twitter [inaudible] squad.
The death squad podcast is
also available on iTunes.
It's with red band and a
bunch of different comics.
So Sam triply Arusha fears,
got shows on at Thompson girls got
shows on it. It's fantastic. There's,
there's fucking a new
podcast almost every day.
You're doing like four or five a week,
and I'll have this sensor to
use during video. Uh, tonight.
Sal's comedy hole in La this Wednesday
around Wednesday. One to set a sure.
Fuck yeah. Bill burrs in the house. Sound
Comedy Hills. This shit. It's on Melrose.
It will sell out quickly.
It's only about 80 seats.
We do it almost every Wednesday.
Um, Portland this weekend. Oh No.
Seattle this weekend. More theater
almost sold out. Very few tickets left.
Don't sleep, bitches. And
we'll see you tonight at a,
the smog castle in Hollywood.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you to the fleshlight for
sponsoring this show. Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click the link. Enter in the
code name rogue and get 15% off.
Thank you to bill burr.
Thank you to Brian Redman.
You know I love you crazy
bitch. I love you. We love you.
Silly Bitch.
You silly pitch.
I love all you fucking
[inaudible].